WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED WITH OUR COMMITTEE HERE
YOU'LL SEE THAT OUR COMMITTEE IS
SMALL RIGHT NOW.
BUT THERE'S A COUPLE OF US THAT
CAN -- WE GET THIS -- GET THE
COMMITTEE STARTED SO JUST SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE WE BEGIN --
THIS IS A HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR
SPOCK ISSUEWHEN MAKE SURE
YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT PLACE -- WE
DO HAVE A WILL HAVE TIME LIMITS
TODAY -- WE'LL HEAR TWO
WITNESSES PER SIDE WITH A TIME
LIMIT OF THREE MINUTES EACH.
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WE ASK THE STATE ONLY THEIR NAME
AN ORGANIZATION OR POSITION ON
THE MEASURE -- WE HAVE SOME
BILLS PROPOSED FOR A CONSENT
TODAY.
OF THE ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT OUR ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR POTTER -- PAN.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO ZERO
SEVEN BY.
SENATOR HER TADO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB TWO FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
DODD ITEM NUMBER NINE SB THREE
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR PAN.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB THREE EIGHTY
TWO BY SENATOR NIELSEN AND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB SEVEN OH SIX
BY SENATOR GALGIANI WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM WE CAN TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- BUT AT THIS
POINT WE ARE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
SO WE ARE GOING TO DO.
I BELIEVE THAT -- THE FIRST
ORDER I THINK SENATOR WIENER IS
GOING TO PRESENT FIRST -- AND
THEN -- SENATOR TO RAZA WILL
COME LATER SO YOU HAVE TO BILLS
BEFORE CENTER WE HEARING GOING
TO START WITH SENATE BILL
.
FORTY AS YOU WISH.
I THANK YOU I MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ON STARTING WITH A SENATE BILL
FORTY I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF -- FOR WORKING.
WITH US AS WE DID LAST YEAR WITH
US WITH HIM FORTY FIVE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WORKED VERY CLOSELY
AND COOPERATIVELY WITH US -- IT
WHICH MAKES THE PROCESS A LOT
EASIER AND SO WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE.
OF THAT AND AS YOU KNOW -- WE
ARE CROSSED AMENDMENTS -- BEFORE
JUDICIARY REFLECTING ALL OF THE
DURING THE AGREED -- TO AND THEM
AND SO THAT IS -- IMPRINT -- SB --
FORTY IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT THE HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP --
BILL THAT WE PASSED LAST YEAR SB --
TEN FORTY FIVE CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED -- GUY --
DOING WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE GOING TO UNDERMINE
IMPLEMENTATION.
ON AS WELL AS DOING CONTINUING
TO DO WORK TO ENSURE -- THAT
THIS IS TRULY A LAST RESORT --
THERE WERE RESPECTING THE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES
OF PEOPLE UNDER CONSIDERATION
FOR CONSERVATORSHIP IN THE WERE
STRIKING THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE.
BETWEEN HELPING TO SAVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES WHO WERE IN SEVERE
DISTRESS AND VERY DEBILITATED
BECAUSE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES.
WHILE ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT
CONSERVATORSHIP IS A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T STRAIN
SOMEONE'S FREEDOM FOR A PERIOD.
OF TIME I THINK WE HAVE STRUCK
THAT BALANCE AND I THINK SB
FORTY WILL ALLOW THE HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HAS ALREADY VOTED
TO OPT IN -- AND POTENTIALLY --
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTY - WE ARE SEEING A CRISIS
UNFOLDING ON OUR STREETS AND AND
TO MANY PLACES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN SPEAK FROM US
CERTAINLY FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ARE PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SEVERE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER -- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT -- PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES WERE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
INCAPABLE OF MAKING DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES INCAPABLE.
OF ACCEPTING VOLUNTARY SERVICES
AND WHO ARE UNRAVELLING AND
ULTIMATELY DYING ON OUR STREETS
USE OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE SEE.
ON THE STREETS SLEEPING IN THEIR
OWN FECES ARE RUNNING OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STREET SCREAMING
OUR CARS -- PEOPLE WHERE PEOPLE
WALK BY.
OUR CONSTITUENTS WALK BY.
AND SAY WHY IS NO ONE DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS PERSON THIS
PERSON NEEDS HELP THIS PERSON IS
IN CRISIS.
AND THE REASON IS THAT OUR LAWS.
THAT WERE ADOPTED IN RESPONSE.
TO THE VERY IN HUMANE HOSPITALS
OF THE PAST WHERE PEOPLE WERE
BEING HOSPITALIZED WHO DIDN'T
NEED TO BE THERE -- THESE THE
LAWS IN SOME.
CASES ARE TOO RESTRICTIVE IN
TERMS OF GETTING PEOPLE THE HELP.
THEY NEED I SAID THIS LOT BILL
WILL HELP US GET PEOPLE THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED -- TO EVEN BE
ELIGIBLE EVEN TAKE THE FIRST
STEP TO BE IT EVEN AS AN INITIAL
MATTER ELIGIBLE A PERSON HAS TO
BE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES.
AT LEAST EIGHT TIMES AND A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD -- UNDER
AMENDMENTS THAT WE TAKE AND YOU
HAVE TO RECEIVE NOTICE THAT WHEN
YOU GOT TO BE A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
THAT YOU MIGHT BE A CANDIDATE --
FOR CONSERVATORSHIP -- WE HAVE
RESTRUCTURED THIS
CONSERVATORSHIP -- SO THAT YOU
START WITH A ON AFTER THE EIGHT
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES -- THERE'S A
TEMPORARY CONSERVATORSHIP OF
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS SO WE START ON
THE SHORTER SIDE -- AN
EVALUATION WILL HAVE TO HAPPEN --
THEN THERE WILL BE WHATEVER
JUDICIAL PROCESS -- IS REQUIRED
COULD BE A COURT TRIAL ON A
COULD BE A JURY TRIAL THE PERSON
WILL AS ALWAYS -- HAVE --
COUNCIL IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER.
AND THEN IF A IF -- THE
EVALUATION SUPPORT SAID IN THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS SUPPORTS THAT.
IT CAN BE EXTENDED TO A FULL SIX
MONTH CONSERVATORSHIP -- WITH
REGULAR REPORT BACKS IN CASE
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO TERMINATE
THE CONSERVATORSHIP.
OUR EARLY ON SO THIS -- I THINK
IT'S A GOOD APPROACH AND TO
BALANCE APPROACH I BELIEVE IT
WILL SAVE LIVES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO --
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY -- FROM
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO OUR DOCTOR ANGELICA
ALMEIDA WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF
FORENSIC AND JUSTICE INVOLVED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND CAPTAIN SIMON PAYING -- FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
ARE YOU CAN -- THAT IS A SAVIOR.
YEAH AND YOU MIGHT WANNA SIT
OVER HERE.
GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR WOULD IN
COMMITTEE -- GOOD AFTERNOON IT
WOULD HELP IF I KNEW WHAT TIME
OF DAY IT WAS.
FEELS LIKE IT'S A MORNING STILL.
THAT'S A LONG DAY.
GOOD MORNING -- TO GET I DID IT
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
WOULDN'T COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY
NAME IS DOCTOR AND TELECOM MADE
A AND I'M THE DIRECTOR FRIENDS
LIKE IN JUST INVOLVE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
INCLUDING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
AND COORDINATION FOR LPS
CONSERVATORSHIP.
ON BEHALF OF MERE BREED AND THE
CITY AND COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
HEARING THIS FILM AND I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR SCOTT WEINER FOR
HIS CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP IN CALLING ATTENTION
TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE CRISIS
ON OUR STREETS AND ACROSS OUR
STATE AND COUNTRY.
AND THERE ARE MANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND ARE SUFFERING
FROM BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE NEEDS. FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE REALITY IS A SAD
REPEATING CYCLE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS GOING IN
AND OUT OF THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND IN SOME CASES BEING ARRESTED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS DAMAGING TO THEIR HEALTH
AND OVERALL WELL BEING.
AS A PROVIDER I CAN SHARE THAT
THESE ARE THE CASES I STRUGGLE
WITH BECAUSE OUR CURRENT LAWS
ARE AN ADEQUATE TO SUPPORT AND
STABILIZE THEM.
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
SB TEN FORTY FIVE WHICH CREATES
AN OPTIONAL NEW CONSERVATORSHIP.
IN THE NUMBER OF MONTHS AS WE
STARTED TO PREPARE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TEN FORTY
FIVE WE'VE IDENTIFIED A FEW
AREAS OF THE BILL THAT NEEDS
SOME MODIFICATION TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN SERVE THE POPULATION THAT
WE INTENDED TO SIR.
SB FORTY INCLUDE THOSE
MODIFICATIONS REINFORCES THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF SB TEN FORTY
FIVE AND OFFERS AS A WAY TO
REACH AND SUPPORT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN A RESIDENCE.
IT HOWEVER DOES NOT EXPAND THE
POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS
ELIGIBLE FOR HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP WHICH IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS ESTIMATED TO BE
BETWEEN FIFTY AND SEVENTY FIVE
OUR CITY HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
BEING INNOVATIVE AND PROVIDING
COMPASSIONATE CARE AND EITHER I
AND MY COLLEAGUES OR MERE BREED.
TAKE LIGHTLY THE IDEA OF
LIMITING ANYONE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE AND THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
WEIGHING IT IS OUR MORAL ETHICAL
AND LEGAL LEGAL OBLIGATION.
BUT WE MUST NOT TURN BACK ON
THOSE IN NEED AND I'M HERE
BECAUSE WE HAD THE A CHANCE TO
MAKE A MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE.
AND WITH THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FORTY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING JUST THAT.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THIS ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
CHAIRMAN WOULD ANOTHER MEMBERS.
I AM PART OF THE SAN CISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENTS COMMUNITY PARAMEDIC
TEAM.
MSX.
WE PARTNER WITH OTHER CLINICIANS
TO CONNECT FREQUENTS USERS AT
EMS TO SYSTEMS OF CARE.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT FOR A SMALL
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SEVERE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
NO AMOUNT OF ENGAGEMENTS OR
SERVICE OFFERS WILL IMPROVE
THEIR SITUATION.
I'LL GET EXAMPLES.
JOHN WHO DIED IN AN ER.
HAVING BEEN FOUND HYPOTHERMIC BY
PARAMEDICS.
HE WAS DIABETIC MATH USER.
AND CHRONICALLY INCONTINENT.
HE HAD MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
EMERGENCY RESPONSES THE YEAR
BEFORE HE DIED.
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF BYSTANDERS SAW
A LEGLESS PERSON COVERED IN
EXCREMENT TO COULDN'T GET BACK
INTO HIS WHEELCHAIR.
FRANK AMET USER.
SITS IN HIS WHEELCHAIR AND
EXCREMENT ALL DAY HE HAS AN
ABSCESS ON HIS BACKSIDE THAT HAS
TUNNEL DOWN TO THE BONE.
SOMETIMES HE WILL TRY TO GET OUT
OF HIS WHEELCHAIR TO DEFECATE IN
THE OPEN.
FIRST RESPONDERS FIND HIM
COVERED IN FECES HIS WOUNDS
EXPOSED.
UNABLE TO PULL UP HIS PANTS AND
GET BACK IN HIS WHEELCHAIR.
AND THE LAST TWO YEARS HE HAS
ACTIVATED NINE ONE ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO TIMES.
RICHARD ANOTHER MAC USER USE
NINE ONE ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT TIMES IN ONE YEAR.
HE REPEATEDLY REFUSES SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AND RIDES THE BUS ALL NIGHT.
USUALLY.
SOIL THAN EXCREMENT.
AND ASKED PEOPLE TO CALL 911-
WHEN HE GETS TOO ANXIOUS.
THIS ONE'S HAPPENED FOUR TIMES
IN ONE EVENING.
YET ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL WAS
ADMITTED TO THE INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT FOR LIFE THREATENING
CONDITIONS TWENTY ONE TIMES
BETWEEN JANUARY AND APRIL OF
THIS YEAR.
YET HE INSISTED ON LEAVING SO HE
COULD USE METH AND HEROIN.
SEVERAL TIMES HE WAS RELEASED
AGAINST MEDICAL ADVICE AND RE
ADMITTED THE VERY SAME DAY.
HE DIED IN MAY.
WE NEED SB TEN FORTY FIVE AND SB
FORTY AS A MEANS OF STOPPING
TRAGIC AND UNNECESSARY DEATHS ON
THE STREETS.
PLEASE HELP COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS
DO THE WORK SO DESPERATELY
NEEDED FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE SERVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF SB.
FORTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RENTAL HAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THREE ONE
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY SO SUPPORT.
TAMERA JIMENEZ WITH ANAHEIM
WHITE HOUSE -- DETOX AND
TREATMENT CENTER FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
YOUR POWER [inaudible]
ERICA [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
JUST WANT TO START OUT THINK --
THE COMMITTEES ABOUT THE CHAIR
STAFF WHO'VE WORKED WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I THINK
SIGNIFICANTLY MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO TO THIS BILL --
AND SOME OF THE KEY PIECES THAT
WE THINK WE'RE VERY IMPORTANT --
TWO THE BILL WERE FIRST OF ALL
SHORTENING THE LENGTH OF TIME
INITIALLY -- THE TEMPORARY --
CONSERVATORSHIP WAS -- MUCH
LONGER SHORT NOW 228- DAYS --
THERE ARE NOW REPEATED NOTICES
TO INDIVIDUALS -- YEAH BEFORE
THEY HIT THE EIGHT FIFTY ONE
FIFTIES -- THAT THEY MAY BE
SUBJECT TO THE FIFTY ONE OR TO
THE VOLUNTARY CONSERVATORSHIP
ND AND ULTIMATELY A
CONSERVATORSHIP -- UNDER THE
BILL IMPORTANTLY THERE'S AN
EVALUATION NOW -- OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WHICH WAS NOT
HAPPENING -- EARLIER AND THERE'S
ALSO THE REQUIREMENT OF OUR FOR
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT SERVICES --
ALONG THE WAY SO WITH ALL OF
THOSE WE THINK THAT -- THOSE ARE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS HOWEVER
WE DO STILL REMAINED -- OPPOSED
TO BECAUSE THIS BILL LIKE TEN
FORTY FIVE DOES YOUR VIEW
CONTINUE -- TO TAKE AWAY A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE UNDER --
THE THE CURRENT LAW FOR IT FOR
DECADES LPS HAS WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS SPENT A CRITICAL BALANCE
BETWEEN INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND
THE THE SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS
AND AND THE THE PUBLIC AND WE
THINK NOW -- SP FORTY AS A
DEMAND STAND FORTY FIVE DOESN'T
INCLUDE THOSE SAME --
PROTECTIONS -- THE OTHER
CRITICAL PIECE THAT I THINK YOU
HEARD FROM OUR TESTIMONY THROUGH
TEN FORTY FIVE AND NOW AND THIS
BILL IT REMAINS IS THAT THERE
ARE NOT ANY ASSURANCES OF THE
RESOURCES THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN --
RECEIVE -- AND AND PARTICULARLY --
WE HAVE ADVOCATED THAT THERE
SHOULD BE -- THE OPPORTUNITY AND
INDEED THE OFFER -- OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING -- FOR FOR
INDIVIDUALS -- IN PARTICULARLY
WHERE IN IN SAN FRANCISCO --
THIS THE CHRONICLE CONTINUES TO
REPORT THAT WE'VE GOT A BROKEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM --
THERE AND WHAT IS CRITICAL IS
THE NEEDED RESOURCES FOR BOTH
HOUSING AND BEHAVIORAL AND
MEDICAL -- TREATMENT THAT WE
DON'T THINK OTHERWISE EXISTS OF
THIS BILL AGAIN LIKE -- TEN
FORTY FIVE IS PUTTING THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE SO WITH THE
THAT WE CONTINUE -- TO URGE YOUR
NO VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- THE INITIAL BILL
SB TEN FORTY FIVE AND SB FIFTY
ARE STILL VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON
STATUS RATHER THAN CONDITION
WHAT WAS WRITTEN ORIGINALLY
HOMELESS CONSERVATORSHIP IS NOW
I HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP AND
IT'S BASED ON SOMEONE STATUS OUR
HISTORY OF ARRESTS AND THEIR
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES -- CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT HAVE A GOOD HISTORY OF
CONFINEMENT IT'S CONFINED IN
JAILS ARE CONFINED AND HOSPITALS
WE TEND TO CONFINE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOW INCOME AND WHO ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR -- SO ANY TIME
WE'RE VENTURING FORWARD TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO COMBINE PEOPLE
THESE ARE REAL CONCERNS THAT WE
WON IT TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
WE ARE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REMOVAL OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR
OUT PATIENT ASSISTANCE -- AND
FOR THOSE REASONS REMAIN OPPOSED
BUT I DO CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUE AND AND VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE MEN'S THAT WERE DONE IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH I
UNDERSTAND CONSULTING WITH THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL -- WE
ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THAT
AMENDMENTS INCREASING THE DUE
PROCESS WILL ACTUALLY HELP
PEOPLE GET TO THE SERVICES THEY
NEED SHOULD THIS MOVE FORWARD
AND THAT THE EVALUATION PIECE IS
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
CONTINUE. TO MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKES WE'VE ALWAYS HAD MADE
WHEN CONFINING INDIVIDUALS I DO
URGE YOUR NO VOTE -- AND BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
SHARED CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR
IN TERMS OF WE ALL AGREE THAT
THERE'S A CRISIS.
BUT IT'S VERY MUCH A HOUSING
CRISIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF LC I YOU CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR AND TO
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTS.
HOOP AND VASTLY IMPROVE THE BILL
WE'RE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THAT THE SERVICES WILL BE
AVAILABLE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT SAN
FRANCISCO'S MADE SOME STEPS TO
TO DO THAT BUT WE'RE STILL
CONCERNED THAT.
PEOPLE.
GET THE HOUSING THAT THE CONCERT
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE RESOURCES
FOR THE CONSERVATIVES.
AND AND THAT WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE EVALUATION SO WE REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT WE'RE THANKFUL FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK EVERYONE PUT
IN TO IMPROVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEE KNOWN WE GONNA STOP BRIEFLY --
AND TAKE ROLE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND IT'S A PRECIOUS THING SO
MEDITECH [inaudible]
WAIT HERE.
MAYES SPEAR AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE CARRILLO FLORA.
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
OKAY OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM IT
TOOK A MINUTE FOR ITS I'VE READ
ALMOST OUT OF FINGERS BUT
GENERAL I KNOW.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND BY WAS A YEAR
CURRY -- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS RECORD.
YEAH I THINK YOU ARE I SAID I
SUPPORT THIS SITE I SAT IN ON
JUDICIARY COUPLE YEARS AGO AND
THEN WE HEARD THE NEXT WEEK AND
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND THE
TESTIMONY WAS -- VERY COMPELLING.
AND WHILE I'M VERY.
SUPPORTIVE OF THE OPPOSITION
ARGUMENTS AND I'M NOT SURE THE
CONDITIONS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND AND FREEDOM AND IT IS JUST
ON INTERNAL SITUATION FOR
ANYBODY -- I WILL SAY THAT I
THINK I TOLD YOU BEFORE IKNOW
THIS IS A NEGOTIATION OF HAVING
JUST THOSE FEW COUNTIES I THINK.
OBVIOUSLY THIS ISSUE.
IS RIGHT OUTSIDE HERE OUR STATE
CAPITOL DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO SO.
AT SOME POINT LIKE TO SEE THIS
EXPAND INTO OTHER COUNTIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT ELSE OF THIS?
CAR IN THIS -- SKEWS ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING THIS FOR
IT AND I WANT TO THANK THE
POLICE AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE THEIR
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
SUPPORT.
THIS WILL PUT.
THANK YOU AND JUST TO REITERATE --
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE AS
WELL HAVING COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SEEING WHAT OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY FOLKS DEAL WITH.
IT'S THE TESTIMONY IS ACTUALLY
REALITY I MEAN IS BRUTAL REALITY
OF WHAT THEY'RE FACING OUT THERE --
YOU KNOW IT IN IN IT JUST BREAKS
MY HEART TO SEE PEOPLE AND WE'VE
ALL SEEN THEM.
WHO LIVES COMPLETELY LOST THE
DIGNITY AS HUMAN YOU KNOW AND
AND AND THE HUMAN CONDITION?
HOW WE COULD NOT STEP UP AND
INTERVENE WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO DO TO MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS OR WHATEVER IT?
COMES TO BE THEY CAN'T CARE FOR
THEMSELVES AND ARE PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN THESE POSITIONS AT
ITS HEART WRENCHING SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THEM [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SO SAY THE BILL DOESN'T DO IT
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS I KNOW IT'S BEEN.
QUITE A JOURNEY -- TO GET HERE
AND I KNOW THERE WAS A LOT OF
WORK THAT WENT ON BEHIND THE
SCENES -- I TOO AM CONCERNED
OBVIOUSLY ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR THEIR
THEIR LIBERTIES -- I THINK THE
STORIES AND I KNOW THAT'S JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG TOLD BY.
OUR EMS PERSON HERE ARE PRETTY
HORRIFYING AND YOU KNOW JUST
HOUSING SOMEONE ISN'T GOING TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM THERE'S
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT THEY NEED --
AS WELL AND SO -- SO I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THIS -- I WISH IT WASN'T
THE WAY IT IS OUT THERE -- BUT
CLEARLY WE HAVE PEOPLE HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CHALLENGES AND WITH THAT --
I'D LIKE TO LET YOU CLOSE IF YOU
LIKE.
THANK YOU JUST GIVE MY CLOTHES
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND I'VE A
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
WEINER WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER CREE AYE
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ALONE.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
I NAZARIAN.
RAMOS.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
WE HAVE A BOTH SETS ENOUGH TO
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE -- YOU HAVE
A SECOND BILL I JUST WANNA MAKE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT -- TO AND SHOULD
HAVE DONE THIS EARLIER AND I
DIDN'T READ FAR ENOUGH DOWN --
WE DO HAVE US WILL HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS ITEM
NUMBER.
FIFTEEN SB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL BE TAKEN UP AT TWO O'CLOCK
TO ACCOMMODATE WITNESSES.
SO -- I SEE SENATOR DRAWS -- OUT
THERE AND I A CHECK OF COFFEE OR
SO MIGHT BE A FEW MINUTES OKAY.
SO -- SENATOR WIENER PLEASE --
PROCEED WITH SB.
ONE FIFTY NINE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN HOPEFULLY.
PROPOSAL MOVED QUICKLY -- SO --
FOR SOME IT'S CHAIRMAN I WANT --
TO THANK ARE YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US WERE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS -- IN ADDITION -- AS
WE DISCUSSED -- WE'RE REQUESTING
TO ADDITIONAL AUTHOR AMENDMENTS --
TO ADDRESS THE REQUESTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SPECIFICALLY TO REMOVE A
LANGUAGE RELATING TO
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT.
AND TO REMOVE -- THE REQUIREMENT
FOR A PHARMACIST ORDER BLOOD
WORK -- MY UNDERSTANDING
ALTHOUGH I WILL LET THEM SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES I THINK THOSE ARE
THE TWO ISSUES THAT IDENTIFIED
SO -- SO THIS SIZE -- THE
PURPOSE OF SB ONE FIFTY NINE IS
TO EXPAND ACCESS. TO A PRE
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS KNOWN AS
PREP AND POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS KNOWN AS PAP --
THESE ARE TWO INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL HIV -- PREVENTATIVE --
PREP IS A ONCE A DAY PILL --
THAT IF YOU TAKE A CONSISTENTLY
REDUCES YOUR RISK OF HIV
INFECTION BY UP 299% -- PAT IS
FOR POST EXPOSURE -- WHERE IF
YOU BELIEVE YOU'VE BEEN ARE
EXPOSED IF YOU START WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS YOU CAN --
HELP PREVENT THE VIRUS FROM
TAKING HOLD IN THE BODY IS A
REVOLUTIONARY -- DRUGS BACKING
AND THE EPIDEMIC THE CAN AND NEW
HIV INFECTIONS THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE -- IS ACCESS -- AND
ARE MET -- HUGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN THE STATE IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THIS WORLD WHO SHOULD BE ON
CRAFT -- BUT ARE NOT --
DISPROPORTIONATELY --
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT FRANKLY
ONCE YOU GET OUTSIDE OF SOME
URBAN AREAS IT'S PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE -- AND WE HAVE TO DO
MORE TO EXPAND ACCESS AND YES
DRUG PRICES ARE TOO HIGH THERE
ARE.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT BARRIERS TO
ONE OF THE BARRIERS -- IS THAT --
IF.
AND WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS
WILL ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO
PROVIDE THE FIRST SIXTY DAYS OF
CRAP.
AND THE ENTIRE TWENTY EIGHT DAY
COURSE A PAP WITHOUT A
PHYSICIAN'S PRESCRIPTION -- AND
THEN AFTER SIXTY DAYS ON PROP A
PERSON WERE TRANSITION INTO A
PHYSICIAN'S CARE.
ON ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
HAD WITH ACCESS -- WE HAVE A
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE AND MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE FROM PEOPLE
SOMETIMES STRUGGLE TO GET A
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT -- IT MAY
TAKE A MONTH OR TWO TO EVEN SEE
A PHYSICIAN AND WHEN SOMEONE
KNOWS THAT THERE ARE AT RISK --
THEY NEED ACCESS RIGHT NOW --
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL -- WILL
HELP US -- TO DO -- SO THE BILL --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING -- CLOSELY --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OF FOR SOME TIME --
AND WITH THESE LAST TWO
AMENDMENTS -- WE BELIEVE THAT --
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THEIR
OPPOSITION WILL COME OFF LOOKING
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES -- AND I
WANT TO THANK -- THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
FOR WORKING WITH US INTERNET
SUMMARY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
OUR COLLABORATION --WITH ME --
TODAY -- OUR SKY LEAVES A
POSITION FROM UC DAVIS.
I'M CORNY MARIN PEARSON WITH SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION -- AND
THEN TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS REAL LOPEZ WHO IS A
PHARMACIST.
THE OWNER OF THE MISSION
WELLNESS PHARMACY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND TAMMY MAR AND WITH
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU PLEASE. FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
SB ONE FIFTY NINE MY NAME IS
ACTORS KILEY AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR OF FAMILY MEDICINE IT
IN HIV SPECIALIST PROVIDER.
I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY
PATIENTS MR J. A GAME ANNA RIGHT
FOR NEW VISIT IF I DID THAT HE
HAD WANTED TO START PROP SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO.
BUT HAD LEFT WITHOUT A
PRESCRIPTION AS HE WAS TOLD THE
MEDICATION WAS UNNECESSARY WHICH
IS NOT WHAT THE CDC IN U. S.
PREVENTIVE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDS.
ANY LEFT FEELING ASHAMED HIS
STORY IS ALL TOO COMMON EVERY
DAY HE WAITED INCREASES RISK OF
HIV REMINDING ME OF MY OTHER
PATIENT MISS ASK.
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE WHO
IS DIAGNOSED WITH HIV AT AGE.
SEVENTEEN SB ONE FIFTY NINE
WOULD GIVE PATIENTS LIKE MR J.
ANOTHER AVENUE TO TAKE CONTROL
OF THEIR HEALTH AND COULD HAVE
PREVENTED EACH IDEA MISS US.
HAPPENED PEP ARE IMPORTANT
EFFECTIVE AND SAFE MEDICATIONS
TO RENT A LIFE ALTERING ILLNESS.
MY PHARMACIST COLLEAGUES ARE
QUALIFIED TO WRITE SAFELY PRATT
AND PAT.
AND WE NEED TO EMPOWER COMMUNITY
PHARMACISTS DIVIDE THESE
MEDICATIONS SB ONE FIFTY NINE
WOULD INCREASE PROP HAD ACCESS
AND IS NECESSARY IF WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT ENDING HIV
TRANSMISSION AND GETTING.
TO ZERO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS COURTNEY MAHER PEARSON AND
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION WORK AB HOW CO
SPONSORS OF SB.
ONE FIFTY NINE WHICH WOULD --
HELP INCREASE PREP AND ACCESS
ACROSS THE STATE AND WILL HELP
MAKE SURE THAT PAT IS AVAILABLE
TO ALL WHO NEED IT.
CURRENTLY PRESS UPS UPTAKE AS
YOU'VE HEARD ACROSS THE STATE IS
TO LOVE MUCH LOWER THAN WE NEED
IF WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS OF GETTING TO ZERO NEW HIV
INFECTIONS.
DESPITE EFFORTS TO MAKE PROP AND
HAVE WIDELY AVAILABLE AT TAKE IS
LOWEST AMONG THE POPULATIONS
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT.
WHO COULD MOST BENEFIT INCLUDING
BLACK AND THAT NEXT GAME MEN AND
BISEXUAL MEN AND WOMEN AND USE?
THESE COMMUNITIES MAY EXPERIENCE
MULTIPLE BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
PREP INCLUDING STATE
MATHEMATICAL MISTRUST.
AND AN INSUFFICIENT NUMBER
PROVIDERS WHO ARE COMFORTABLE
PRESCRIBING HAPPENED PAT.
UNNECESSARY INSURANCE PLAN PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION SHOULD NOT ADD TO
THOSE BARRIERS. FOR EXAMPLE IN
JUST THE LAST -- TWO OR SO
MONTHS WE'VE RECENTLY HAD A
NUMBER OF PATIENTS WHO TRIED TO
ACCESS PAT AFTER AN EXPOSURE.
AND BEEN UNABLE TO BECAUSE THEIR
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION ON THEIR
INSURANCE PLAN TAKES MORE THAN
THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS AT THE THE
MEDICATION AS EFFECTIVE.
THIS WOULD AYE OBVIOUSLY PUT
THEM OUTSIDE OF THE AFFECT
INVESTMENT OVER THE MEDICATION --
AND IS COUNTER TO OUR EFFORTS AT
THE STATE TO EXPAND ACCESS --
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
OPERATES ONE OF THE LARGEST
PRIVATE PROVIDERS IN A PET
CLINICS AND IN THE CITY AND WE
HAVE PRESS NAVIGATORS ON STAFF
WERE ABLE TO DO ALL OF THESE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THEY STILL ARE --
INCREASINGLY BURDENED BY MORE
AND MORE STEPS AND REQUIREMENTS
AND THINGS THAT JUST MAKE ACCESS
HARDER -- AND NOT IN A VERY WELL
RESOURCE CITY WHERE WHERE YOU
KNOW RELEASED HAVE A GOAL OF
INCREASING HAVE ACCESS BUT IF
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
ACCESSES EQUITABLE ACROSS THE
STATE -- WHERE RESOURCES ARE NOT
THERE TO DO THIS KIND OF --
HEALTH NAVIGATION WE REALLY NEED
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE -- MEDI
CAL REMOVE THE TAR FOR PAT AND
PAT BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
BECAUSE THEY SAW THAT IT WAS
CAUSING AN UNNECESSARY BARRIER
TO CARE IT'S WELL PAST TIME FOR
PRIVATE INSURANCE PLANS IN THE
STATE TO FOLLOW SUIT.
THANK YOU.
CHRISTIAN RIVERSIDE IN MY
OPENING I APOLOGIZE I DID I
FOCUS SO MUCH ON THE PHARMACY
ASPECT THE BILL ALSO WILL ON
ELIMINATE -- AND BAND
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS FROM --
INSURANCE COMPANIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT -- JUST YOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEN VALDERRAMA
WHAT THE WHITE AMEND GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS
WERE CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S IN THE MEN'S WORK AND WE
HAVE A SO YOU OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REGULAR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HUNTINGTON SHARP REPRESENTING
THE HELP OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DR DESCRIBE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAMERA JIMENEZ MOM OF IT --
PROUD MOM OF AN LGBTQ PLUS CHILD.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PAUL YOU ARE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO STRONG SUPPORT.
LATOYA THOMPSON PHARMACIST THAT
MISSION WELLNESS PHARMACY AND
SUPPORT.
MASON COREY -- UCSF SCHOOL OF
PHARMACY -- STUDENT PHARMACIST
AS WELL AS A PREPARATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RACHEL PAYING STERN PHARMACISTS
FROM TALL UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR JOHNSON WITH NELSON MARKS ARE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HI I'M JULIE CHAPMAN
REPRESENTING INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO HERE IN SUPPORT.
HI I'M JENNIFER SOMOS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A TWEENER POSITIONS SO --
WE TOOK A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE BILL.
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT PROP AND
PEPPER IMPORTANT BUT THE M. FOUR
DID HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH
ALLOWING A PHARMACIST TO USE
PART BECAUSE IT REQUIRES REGULAR
MONITORING I'M AWARE THAT
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT MOMENT
SINCE THAT TIME.
SO WE WILL BE TAKING THIS BILL
BACK TO OUR BOARD AND ARMY IN
AUGUST AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
THINKING THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE ONE CANNOT BE HAVE
THIS SITUATION A CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WERE ALSO BUT IT BETWEEN -- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION BUT WE DID PROVIDE AN
AMENDMENT TO THE AUTHORS STAFF
TO CONSIDER ABOUT POTENTIALLY
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T.
UNDULY INCREASE THE COST OF
THESE DRUGS BY EXPANDING THE
COVERAGE OPTIONS AND WANTED TO
LIMIT IT -- TO AT LEAST ONE
OPTION AVAILABLE WITHOUT PRIOR
AUTH AND GIVEN THAT WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO OPEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AT THE BILL MOVES
FOR AND HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU. ONE CAR ALL THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE AND OF THE
AUTHOR I THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
AND MOVE O A NEW NEUTRAL
POSITION WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
RIGHT SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS TO
SHIP NINE I THANK THE COMMITTEE
IN THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSE LAST
MINUTE POSITION BUT I WILL BE
TAKING THIS NEW BILL BACK TO OUR
ASSOCIATIONS LIKE A RECESS THE
POSITION THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- MISS WALDRON THEN
THE SECULAR KERR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- AS YOU KNOW --
WE'VE DONE NUMEROUS A
LEGISLATION TOGETHER AS WELL I
RESOLUTIONS AND THINGS -- I HAD
A BILL A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD TRAINING OF REOCCURRING
EDUCATION FOR PHYSICIANS --
INSTRUCTION ON PREP AND PAP
BECAUSE WE FOUND -- WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE DATA?
THAT THERE'S A QUITE A FEW
PHYSICIANS WHO DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
IN DISCUSSING PROP OPEN UP WITH
THEIR PATIENTS ARE HAVE NOT BEEN
FAMILIAR WITH IT -- I SERVED IN
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASE HIGH RISK
COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE BEEN GOING
AROUND.
AND DURING THE OFF SEASON SO
VARIOUS AREAS OF THE STATE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALWAYS
FIND WHEN WE TALK TO FOLKS.
IS THE LACK OF ACCESS THE PEOPLE
FEEL.
THAT THEY CAN GO AND ACTUALLY
GET PREP AND PAT OR THE PEOPLE
EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT SO YOU KNOW
THEY THEY HAD A DESIRE.
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS AND THEY
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO SO.
I THINK THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO HELP THAT BECAUSE SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
KNOW ME VOICE PROTECT MY RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND THIS BILL IS
GOING TO HELP.
INCREASE HEALTH ACCESS TO THOSE
RULED SMALL COMMUNITY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
[inaudible]
FOR ANYONE ELSE.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
WAS ENJOY THE BILLS YOU BRING TO
US -- THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT GOES INTO
THIS A LOT OF THOUGHT AS YOU
REPRESENT -- COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU REPRESENT AS WELL AS THE
BROADER BROADER STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO -- IF THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH I TO CLOSE CENTER WIENER I
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- WE DO HAVE --
BUT THAT WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE MUCH OF
TRACK WITH A MOTION -- BY MOTION
BY MISTER RAMOS A SECOND BY
MISTAKE YEAR CURRY -- MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY I GET CURRY I
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE CARRILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLOOR I LIMóN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
SEC.
YES SEVEN THE WEEK UP MISSING
MEMBERS SO -- BELIEVE THE BILL
ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO.
MR ASCENDER DRAWS -- CENTER
ALLEN HAS NOT HERE WE STILL IN
COMMITTEE PRESENT ANOTHER BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
SENATOR ALSO AND WE'LL BE
HEARING.
FROM YOU ON SENATE BILL TWENTY
NINE YES.
OKAY.
YES.
OKAY THANK YOU UP MISTER CHAIR
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NO BEING ABLE TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR IS SOMETHING MOST OF US.
TAKE FOR GRANTED BY NOW
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE GET OLDER.
SB TWENTY NINE ALLOWS ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AGE SIXTY FIVE OR OVER.
WHO MEET THE INCOME AND
RESIDENCY REQUIREMENTS TO
RECEIVE FULL MEDICAL COVERAGE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS?
SEE UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
ARE CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY SENSE
OF THE WORD.
THEY PAY OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAXES EVERY YEAR.
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES BUT
THEY ARE SHUT OUT FROM
PREVENTATIVE CARE.
AND DOCTOR VISITS THAT OTHER
CALIFORNIANS HAVE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
IS UNFAIR AND CRUEL.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AGE SIXTY FIVE OR OVER DON'T
HAVE A REGULAR DOCTOR.
THEY ARE FORCED TO GO TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR CARE.
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS
STRONGER AND MORE COST EFFICIENT
WELL WE DETECT AND TREAT
PREVENTABLE CONDITIONS EARLY.
RATHER THAN FORCE PATIENTS TO
RESORT TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM FOR
CARE.
STUDIES SHOW EMERGENCY CARE COST
THREE TIMES MORE THAN PRIMARY
CARE AND THAT PEOPLE PUT OFF
CARE UNTIL THEY ACTUALLY GET
MUCH MORE BILL.
THAT IS NO WAY TO TREAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE WORKED REYES FAMILIES
AND PAY THEIR SHARE AND TAXES.
OUR ELDERS ARE FORCED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK.
MOST HAVE CHILDREN GRAND
CHILDREN SPOUSES WHO ARE US
CITIZENS AND RESIDENTS.
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS ARE 34% OF
THE WORK FORCE TWICE THE
NATIONAL ELDER AVERAGE.
SOME OF OUR ELDERS HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS FOR A SOLUTION FROM
WASHINGTON TO NO AVAIL.
MANY ARE HELPING TO RAISE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF CALIFORNIANS.
KNOW ELDER SHOULD SUFFER OR DIE
FROM A TREATABLE CONDITION
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY WERE BORN.
TODAY COLLEAGUES WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO ACT AND MOVED
EVEN CLOSER. TO COVERING ALL
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE.
I KNOW THIS MEASURE REQUIRES
FUNDING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
HOWEVER NOTHING SHOULD STOP US
FROM MAKING A POLICY DECISION.
IT SHOULD NO LONGER BE A
QUESTION ABOUT WHY WE NEED TO
COVER THIS POPULATION BUT
INSTEAD HOW WE PROVIDE CARE TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO STOP
THE BAN ON OUR SENIORS -- AND WE
HAVE SOME EXPERTS WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING TODAY SO.
MISC ABOUT PLEASE.
OKAY WHATEVER YOU DECIDE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE JUST A RANDOM WE HAVE
HOPE ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WHAT CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION
I'M HERE TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORTER OF SB TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED EXTEND MEDIC COLLEGE
ABILITY TO LOW INCOME SENIORS
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
CALIFORNIA'S TWO POINT TWO
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS ARE
IT CAN SHOOT CONTRIBUTORY SOCIAL
UP NOT ECONOMIC FABRIC IN THE
STATE. TWO THIRDS OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED HAVE BEEN LIVING
AND WORKING IN THE STATE FOR
OVER A DECADE HOWEVER AS THE
WHICH THEIR SENIOR YEARS.
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS OR MEDICARE
DESPITE HAVING PAID INTO THE
SYSTEM FOR YEARS SIMILAR TO MANY
CITIZENS UNLAWFULLY PRESENT.
WORKERS HAVE DONE WE BELIEVE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STRONGER WHEN
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE THE FOR THE THIRTY
THOUSAND LOW INCOME UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS ACCESS TO CARE IT'S
EITHER LIMITED OR NONEXISTENT.
CURRENTLY A DOCUMENT SENIORS ARE
ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR RICHARD DISCO
FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL.
WHICH ONLY COVERS EMERGENCIES
AND ONLY STABILIZE THE PATIENT
IT DOESN'T TREAT IT MIGHT BE A
CHRONIC CONDITION SUCH AS THIS --
DIABETES OR HEART DISEASE OR
EVEN IF SOMETHING LIKE CANCER IT
DOESN'T COME WITH THE PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDER PREVENTIVE
SERVICES AND MEDICAL HOME OR
EVEN ACCESS TO PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
DEPENDING OR THEY LIVE THEY
MIGHT HAVE ACCESS AND COUNTY
BASEBALL PROGRAMS BUT IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE THE CARE IS
NONEXISTENT.
AS A RESULT MANY UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS ARE LIVING SICKER AND
DYING YOUNGER AND ARE ONLY ONE
MEDICAL EMERGENCY AWAY FROM HOME --
FINANCIAL RUIN YOU TO HIGH
MEDICAL COSTS.
BY PASSING AS BETWEEN NINE WE
CAN ENSURE THAT EVERY SENIOR HAS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WHEN THEY
NEED IT REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
WERE BORN. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBER
STEVEN BACK NATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER -- CO SPONSOR OF SB
TWENTY NINE I'M NOT TOO LONG AGO
WE HEARD A STORY FROM SOMEONE
WHO REACHED OUT TO US WHOSE
MOTHER WAS IN THE HOSPITAL DUE
TO CANCER -- SHE WAS ON
RESTRICTED SCOPE MEDI CAL AND
WASN'T ABLE TO ACCESS THE
SERVICES TO ACTUALLY GET THE
TRANSPLANT THAT SHE NEEDED
BECAUSE THE CANCER GOTTEN SO
SEVERE -- WHICH REQUIRED EITHER
FULL SCOPE OR PRIVATE INSURANCE.
I TWO WEEKS LATER SHE PASSED
AWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS STORY IS NOT
UNIQUE -- THIS HAPPENS IN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE ON A DAILY BASIS AND AND
WE DO HEAR THOSE STORIES.
I WE TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT NO
ONE SHOULD GET A DEATH SENTENCE
JUST BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN EVERYONE DOES DESERVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THOSE SENIORS
THAT ARE LOW INCOME WHICH MANY
OF THEM ARE LIVING IN IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES -- IT'S A REALITY THAT
ESCAPES THEM -- UNDER THIS
PARTICULAR CLIMATE -- OUR
SENIORS YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
LIVING IN A REALLY -- STEVE
DRESS -- WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS WITH PHYSICAL HEALTH
CONCERNS AND WE JUST SEE THE
CRITICAL NATURE HOW URGENT IT IS
TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE THAT IS
COMPREHENSIVE I'M TO EVERYBODY --
BUT ESPECIALLY OUR SENIORS WHO
ARE TRULY IN NEED OF IT AND SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST CAME TO LAND A BIT OF
SUPPORT TO OUR COLLEAGUE IN OUR
SENATOR AND OUR EFFORT AND THE
MOVEMENT TOWARDS HEALTH FOR ALL.
THE WORK THAT YOU AND I DID
MISTER CHAIR LAST YEAR IN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE GET WORKING
TOWARDS.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE AND
LAYING OUT A PLAN.
CLEARLY DEFINED THAT ONE OF THE
STEPS WE HAVE TO TAKE TO GET TO
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IS TO COVER
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY NOT.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO EVERY
EFFORT THAT WE UNDERTAKE.
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE US TOWARDS
THAT GOAL OF UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
SUPPORTING.
SENATOR THAT ALSO AND SB.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BEST HEALTH FOR HEALTH ACCESS
HERE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THE BILL.
SO -- MOTION BY THE SAVIOR KOREA
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO -- OTHERS
IN SUPPORT JUST TO NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS CONNIE
DELGADO AND WE HAVE THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DR DESCRIBE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ME'S WORKING OUT THEY SAY A
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT WE'D ALSO
LIKE OPPOSITION AS BEFORE THE
AYE TO THE RECORDS OF THEIR
INABILITY TO DO SO EARLIER I
THINK YOU.
TIM VALDERRAMA WITH THE
WEATHERMAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HUNTINGTON SHARP WITH THE HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I REGULAR AMERICA'S ON THE HAVE
THE LEADERS OF THAT THE NO
COLLISION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS THAT COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS HERE IN SUPPORT.
CHECK A FREIGHTER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IN A SCAN WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA LATINAS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
REPRESENTING IMMIGRANT FROM MR
THING.
THANK YOU.
GLORIA AROUND WHAT YOU LEARN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HE MASSIVE CHILL IN SUPPORT.
I LETTER THAT I GUESS WITH
CHILLIN SUPPORT.
EVER SHOWING ENTRY LE SPORT
THANK YOU.
I NAY AUTOS CULTURAL AND SUPPORT
CARMEN NOW WITH CHIRLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WICHITA AS A CHALLENGE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MAURICE WHICH SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WELL ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
SO MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MY USER FERNANDES LOTUS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI JULIE CHAPMAN WITH
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CARL SUPPORTER WITH BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
TIM MAD REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE MERIT CALLS
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SPORTS.
PUSH OFF ASSEMBLY WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
KELLY BE MY MY HALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
Q..
PLEASE ISSUE ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
EXACTLY CORPS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRIAN ALISON AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES ALSO STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY THANK YOU.
ON TO SOME BEHALF OF ST JOHN'S
WILL CHILD AND FAMILY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
A DATING IS ALSO WITH AMERICA'S
FISHING GROUPS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARK MENDOZA WITH US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THREE TO START HAS A PERMANENT A
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
PART GO AHEAD PLEASE -- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FOR NO
WORKING ON A AGING PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A PIECE AND I REALLY
DON'T WANNA LEAVE ANYBODY BEHIND
IT'S FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS SO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING
OUT THAT LEGISLATION THROUGH AND
LOVE TO HAVE THIS BE PART OF
THAT AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR -- FOR COMING FORWARD
WITH THIS LEGISLATION -- YEAH I
HAVE LONG BEEN A BELIEVER THAT --
FOR OUR HEALTH SYSTEM TO BE THE
HOT THE HEALTHIEST OF POSSIBLE
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT EVERYBODY BE
A PART OF OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM --
THE THE SIX CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO SEEK
EMERGENCY CARE -- NGUYEN PRIMARY
CARE WOULD BE A MORE COST
EFFECTIVE A MORE HUMANE WAY OF
DELIVERING CARE -- IS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING OF THE PAST -- IT IS
CHALLENGING OBVIOUSLY -- FROM AN
ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE AND TO BE
ABLE TO TO DO THIS AND I THINK
WE HAVE -- MADE SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES THIS YEAR --
WITH OUR BUDGET AND WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND SOME TIME
WITH THE GOVERNOR TODAY. TO
CELEBRATE THAT BUT HE AS I WILL
DO NOW POINTED OUT THAT WE ARE
ON A JOURNEY.
AND THIS JOURNEY WILL TAKE SOME
TIME IN THIS JOURNEY WILL TAKE
SOME RESOURCES AND WE ALSO.
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ROLLING
BACK THE ACA WHICH IS -- WHICH
IS A COMPONENT OF OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR EVERYONE I
DON'T SAY THAT TO BE A WET
BLANKET BUT I JUST SAY THAT --
TO TO THAT WE WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE TO FIGHT TO PROTECT WHAT IS
GOOD AND RIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA
HERE SO I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE AND FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND I THINK IT IS RIGHT THAT WE
HAVE THIS -- THIS IN POLICY AND
SO THAT WHEN THE FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE WE CAN IMPLEMENTED.
AND IT'S A SIMPLE IT'S A SIMPLE
AS THAT SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES PLEASE -- YES I DO I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT GOVERNMENT
INNER NEWSOME SIGNED A BILL.
TO LOWER PRESCRIPTION DRUG AND
HEALTHCARE COSTS. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE.
ARE UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS AND
MANY MANY MORE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
THEY ARE VERY VERY MUCH A PART
OF OUR FAMILIES.
THEY ARE INTEGRATED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THERE WE GO TO CHURCH TOGETHER.
WE GO TO SCHOOL TOGETHER GO TO
WORK TOGETHER THEY OUR US.
AND CALIFORNIA IS THEM.
AND SOMEHOW WE FIND IT OKAY TO
SEGREGATE AND BOUND THEM FOR
WHAT OTHER CALIFORNIANS GET.
THEY CONTINUE TO BE EXCLUDED
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THEIR HEALTHCARE.
IS PUT OFF UNTIL A DAY.
THAT IT WILL BE CONVENIENT FOR
US IT'S REALLY TIME TO ACT.
WE HAVE IT IN OUR POWER WE HAVE
IT IN OUR RESOURCES. TO DO SO.
THERE'S ALWAYS A COST TO
COVERING PEOPLE.
INSTEAD OF LETTING THEM FEND FOR
THEMSELVES AND DIE UNNECESSARILY.
BUT THAT'S THE CHOICE WE HAVE
MADE WITH THIS VERY UNEQUAL
SYSTEM.
IN THE LONG RUN THE COST OF
COVERAGE AND WE SAY THIS OVER
AND OVER WILL FAR OUTWEIGH THE
COST OF DOING NOTHING.
IT IS A DOWN PAYMENT ON THE
HEALTHY FUTURE OF THE ENTIRE
STATE.
THE GOVERNOR SAID TODAY.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE.
YOU BELIEVE IN UNIVERSAL
AND IF WE TRULY BELIEVE IN
HEALTHCARE AS A HUMAN RIGHT.
THEN WE ARE PLEDGED TO CONTINUE
TO FIGHT FOR IT -- I WE SHOULD
ACT ON THAT.
OF I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THAT THIS
COALITION HEALTH FOR ALL DOES
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
EVERYONE WHO SHOWS UP HERE -- IS
A SAMPLE OF THE KIND OF WORK
THAT THEY DO EVERY DAY THIS IS
NOT BEEN EASY -- BUT I GUARANTEE
YOU WITH THE WORK THAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY -- THERE'S NOTHING
THAT WILL INSPIRE ME MORE AND
HOPE NOT PEOPLE -- INSPIRE YOU
MORE THAN TO DO SOMETHING.
AND NOT JUST TALK ABOUT IT SO
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR
WHAT YOU DO -- I THANK ALL OF
YOU CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS --
LET'S FIVE FOR WHAT WE SAY WE
BELIEVE IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR ALSO
A WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE CARILLO I
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOW THE PHONE.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. SIX YOU HAVE SIX VOTES
YOU NEED A COUPLE MORE BUT WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF MEMBERS MISSING SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
SO WE ARE AT KNOWING IT'S A BUSY
DAY.
OUT THERE -- LOTS OF ACTIVITY IN
THE HALLWAYS WE ARE LOOKING FOR
A SENATE AUTHOR.
PREFERRED THE ONE THAT HAS A
BILL BEFORE US.
DOT CENTER HUESO [inaudible]
ON CUE.
YOUR TIMING WAS IMPECCABLE.
LIKE AT YOUR PLACE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON MOVE
THE BILL ON THE BILL ADD LIKE --
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- WILL APPRECIATE
THAT WERE BOTH WORKING TOWARD
THE BOTH GOAL OF OF HELPING TO
BRING PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING.
SOME LEVEL OF OF RELIEF FROM
PAIN.
AND ON UNFORTUNATELY HERE
CALIFORNIA ARE OR LAWS.
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TERMINALLY ILL.
PATIENTS IN DEEP SUFFERING
[inaudible]
FROM.
ACCESS SEEN -- TO RELIEF OPTIONS
AND THIS BILL.
WOULD MAKE IT.
POSSIBLE FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE.
A TERMINALLY ILL.
IN IN HOSPICE -- TO HAVE ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CARE CANNABIS. TO
HELP THEM DEAL WITH.
THE THE NAUSEA VOMITING AND PAN
THAT IS USUALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
SOME OF THE ILLNESSES THAT --
CAN BE [inaudible]
OF HELPED BY THE USE OF MEDICAL
CARE CANNABIS SO.
I I INTRODUCED SB THREE OH FIVE
KNOWN AS RYAN'S LAW. TO HELP
PATIENTS THAT ARE OR FACING SIR
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT -- RHYME
BARTEL HIMSELF -- ENCOUNTERED AT
WHAT HE WAS IN HIS FINAL DAYS I
HAVE HIS FATHER HERE -- JIM
BARTEL THAT.
THAT HIS OF BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
THIS ISSUE STATEWIDE -- HIS
EXPERIENCE.
IN DEALING WITH -- HIS HIS HIS
CHILD.
IS IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WILL.
WILL HELP OTHER FAMILIES IN THE
FUTURE. TO HELP.
THEIR LOVED ONES SCOPE WITH A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME IN THEIR
LIFE.
THE FINAL DAYS OF SOMEBODY'S
LIFE SHOULD BE SPENT.
IN AGONIZING PAIN. FOR IN
UNCONSCIOUSNESS.
IN IN HAVING OF PAIN PAIN
KILLING DRUGS SET ALSO DRIVE
THEM INTO INTO UNCONSCIOUSNESS.
AND SO -- WHAT WOULD WITH THE?
OF COURSE WITH YOUR PERMISSION
IS CHIRLA TWO I'D LIKE MISTER
BARTEL TO SHARE SOME OF HIS.
EXPERIENCE WITH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY YES.
THANK CHAIRMAN WOULD THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF ANY JIM BARTEL I AM THE
FATHER BREMER TELL AND THE
SPONSORS SENATE BILL THREE ZERO
FIVE RISE LAW.
THE COMPASSIONATE.
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CANNABIS AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES ACT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK YOU TODAY --
BEFORE I CONTINUE I WANTED TO
GIVE A SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
HUESO FOR HIS.
SUBORDINATES IN OFFERING THE
BILL.
THANK YOU THEN -- I WANT TO TALK
BRIEFLY ABOUT RYAN SO THAT YOU
CAN HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING OF
WHO HE WAS AND WHY THIS
LEGISLATURE'S OWN PORT TO BE
NAMED IN HIS MEMORY.
RIGHT WAS ALWAYS VERY ACTIVE AND
COMPASSIONATE PERSON GROWING UP
IN SANTEE CALIFORNIA.
IN HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS AN
EXCELLENTSTUDENT GRADUATING
WITH HONORS ACTIVE IN SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES IN SEVERAL SPORTS.
INCLUDING ALL STATE HONORS FOR
HIS CROSS COUNTRY AND JUNIOR
SENIOR YEARS.
HE RECRUITED BY SEVERAL COLLEGES
AND ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEW MEXICO AND RAN TRACK AND
CROSS COUNTRY THERE FOR FOUR
YEARS.
YES SIR FOR FOUR YEARS THE
UNITED STATES COAST GUARD.
HE IS MARRIED TO KATIE AND THEY
HAVE A SON CONNOR.
WHO IS?
TEN RAINY CABLE QUIRK IN CASE
STILL AS WORK IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND MULTI WITH
AUTISTIC AND SAT DOWN SYNDROME
STUDENTS.
GET A JOB TAKES NOT ONLY.
A LOT OF SPECIAL SKILLS BUT ALSO.
GREAT PATIENCE AND COMPASSION IN.
RYAN HAD ALL THOSE QUALITIES.
EFFECTIVE WITH THE STUDENTS.
ANY LUCK WITH -- WORKING WITH
THEM AND TOLD ME HOW MUCH IS
GOING TO MISS THEM.
AND MARCH FIRST OF LAST YEAR
RYAN CALLED ME AND MY WIFE. TO
TELL US HE HAD BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH.
STATE FOR PANCREATIC CANCER.
AND ONLY HAD A FEW WEEKS TO LIVE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT I WAS
HEARING.
MY HEART SANK.
HE TURNED FORTY TWO ON MARCH
NINTH WHILE HE'S IN THE HOSPITAL
AND DIED ON APRIL TWENTY FIRST
JUST SEVEN WEEKS AFTER BEING
DIAGNOSED.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN MARCH
FIRST IN APRIL TWENTY FIRST?
IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
IN THE HOSPITAL RIGHT WAS GIVEN
MORPHINE AND SEVERAL OPIOIDS FOR
HIS PAIN RELIEF.
BUT THEY WEREN'T ENOUGH SO THEY
ADDED FENTANYL.
WHICH IS A HUNDRED TIMES MORE
POWERFUL THAN MORPHINE.
IN THE RESULT WAS HE WAS ASLEEP
MOST THE TIME.
DURING ONE OF HIS RARE WAKING
MOMENTS HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT
TO SPEND THE REST OF HIS LIFE
SLEEPING.
AND S. THE I HELP HIM GET OFF
THE PHONE NOW.
AND I PROMISED HIM THAT WOULD.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO SPEND
QUALITY TIME WITH THIS WITH
KATIE AND CONNOR.
HIS PARENTS BROTHER SISTER IN AS
MANY FRIENDS.
I SUGGEST A MEDICAL CAMPUS IS AN
ALTERNATIVE WHICH HE AGREED.
TO WE HAD A MEDICAL CAMERAS
CAMERAS CREATE A CAMPUS MEDICINE
WHICH MEDICINES WHICH WERE
DESIGNED.
TO SLOW DOWN THE GROWTH OF THE
CANCER AND GIVE HIM MORE TIME.
AND CAMPUS MEDICINES FOR PAIN
RELIEF.
BUT WE WERE INFORMED BY THE
HOSPITAL THAT THEIR HOSPITAL
POLICIES NOT A LOT CAMPUS IN THE
HOSPITAL.
THE IRONY THAT POLICY IS THAT
THE PH<c.cyan> NAND OTHER</c>
OPIOIDS TO KILL SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR.
OUR OKAY TO HAVE IN THE HOSPITAL.
BUT THAT MEDICAL CANNABIS WHICH
HAS NEVER KILLED ANYONE.
WE'RE ABLE TO TRANSFER HIM TO
ANOTHER HOSPITAL THAT ALLOWED
CANNABIS THE TOOL IS TO BRING IN
THE MEDICINES.
AND THEY WOULD REFRIGERATE THEM
WITH HIS NAME ON IT AND THEY
WOULD HELP ADMINISTER THE DOSAGE.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T SWALLOW
ANYTHING NOT EVEN WATER THE
CHEMISTRY AT A MEDICAL CANNABIS
SUPPOSITORY DESIGNED TO SLOW THE
GROWTH OF THE CANCER.
AND TO MEDICAL CAMPUS SPRAYS
UNDER THE TONGUE FOR PAIN RELIEF.
HE ALSO USE MEDICAL CAMPUS
PATCHES FOR ANXIETY RELIEF.
THE RESULT WAS AMAZING.
AWAKE AND ALERT DURING THE DAY
HE WAS ABLE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH KATIE AND
CONNOR.
HIS FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS
WITHOUT PAIN.
ALL DAY LONG.
AT NIGHT THEY INCREASE THE
DOSAGE ALLOWED TO SLEEP THROUGH
THE NIGHT.
PAIN FREE.
INSTEAD OF SLEEPING FOR THE
PH<c.cyan> N THE MEDICAL CAMPUS</c>
PROVIDING WITH THE QUALITY OF
LIFE THAT ALLOWED HIM TO HAVE
MUCH NEEDED CONVERSATIONS WITH
HIS FAMILY INTO REMINISCED AND
LAUGHED WITH HIS FRIENDS.
WE CAME TO VISIT.
EVERY TO REALLY -- PATIENT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES RYAN. TO SPEND
THEIR FINAL DAYS WITH MUCH
QUALITY AS MUCH QUALITY AND
DIGNITY AS POSSIBLE.
THEY ARE DYING.
WHY COULDN'T WHY WOULDN'T WE
WANT THAT FOR THEM?
OPTIONS OTHER THAN SEVERE AND
DEBILITATING OPIOIDS LIKE
MORPHINE AND FENTANYL SHOULD BE
ALLOWED. TO HEALTH CARE VISUALLY
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO ALLOW
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS TO USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS AT
THE REQUEST OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
MADE SEVERAL AT IS TO THE BILL.
WHICH BETTER DEFINE THE SCOPE OF
THE ELIGIBLE PATIENTS EXEMPTS
CERTAIN HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
EXEMPTS EMERGENCY ROOMS.
AND SUSPENSE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
BILL FOR ANY HEALTH CARE
FACILITY THIS OBJECTED TO
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
[inaudible]
IN CONCLUSION.
THE HAPPIEST MOMENTS OF MY LIFE
WITH THE FIRST TIME I HELP EACH
OF MY THREE CHILDREN.
THEY WERE BORN.
THE SADDEST WHAT MY LIFE WAS
HOLDING RISE HE AND MEETING HIS
LAST BREATH.
MY HOPE IS THE SADDEST MOMENT
WILL BE MADE LESS PAINFUL BY
ENSURING THAT RYAN'S LAW WILL
OUT THOUSANDS OF OTHER
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS. TO LIVE
THEIR FINAL DAYS WITH QUALITY
AND DIGNITY.
THAT HE WAS ABLE TO EXPERIENCE
BY USING MEDICAL CANNABIS
INSTEAD OF SLEEP INDUCING
OPIOIDS LIKE FENTANYL.
PLEASE SUPPORT RISE LAW THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX OFTEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSE UNLESS
IMMINENT POSITION -- CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THIS MAY PUT US IN THE
CROSSERS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THE
NEW ELEMENTS WE JUST GOT THEM A
FEW HOURS AGO AND REVIEWING HOPE
WE CAN FIND A PATH TO WORK WITH
ARE REGULATED THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- TO RESOLVE
REMAINING CONCERNS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS.
AGAIN DOES CREATE SOME PROBLEMS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE HAVE
PROTECTION THERE SO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
INTERVIEWING AT THE NEW
AMENDMENTS.
AND AND WORKING WITH OUR
REGULATOR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AMY
BLOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES WE ARE PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT AMENDMENTS.
AT THAT THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE PUT FORWARD AND
NOW WORD NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
THE HANDLE SO LEASE YOU KNOW THE
KIND OF THIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAD A
LATE LAST LETTER OF CONCERN LAST
WEEK AND WE ARE INTERESTED TO
LOOK INTO THE AMENDMENTS -- BUT
OUR CONCERN STEMS FROM THE FACT
THAT A NUMBER OF OUR HOSPITALS
ALREADY HAVE SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE ON
THEIR FACILITIES -- RIGHT NOW
IT'S ICE AGENTS -- AND NOT ONLY
ARE THEY INTIMIDATING FAMILY
MEMBERS THE MOST RECENTLY WE
HEARD ESPECIALLY IN OUR SAN
DIEGO LOCATION THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY STARTING TO APPROACH
STAFF.
AND ASK THEM ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND WE WORRY
THAT ANY POLICY.
THAT WOULD PUT OUR HOSPITALS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW
COULD INCREASE THE PRESIDENT
PRESENCE OF OTHER FORMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- AND FURTHER
INTIMIDATE PATIENTS FAMILY AND
NOW HOSPITAL STAFF -- FROM THEIR
VERY IMPORTANT WORK AND SO WE
ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE ADDRESS THERE
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WE VOICE THAT CONCERN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
APOLOGIZE BUT WE SHOULD CREATE A
ON BEHALF OF EASE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
AND SEE NO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO TO
THE LEGISLATURE MISTER BARTEL
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR SON'S
STORY.
I SAW THAT WHEN YOU CAME IN YOU
BROUGHT IN A PHOTO OF YOUR SON
IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE.
FOR MISTER BARTEL TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW US -- THE PHOTO RYAN PLEASE.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WORK THAT WE DO IMPACTS PEOPLE
AND THEN IMPACTS HUMANS HUMAN
LIVES.
THAT'S RYAN.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO ENSURE THAT THE WORK THAT WE
DO WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH.
HAS COMPASSION.
IN IT.
AND WE'RE IN A CHANGING TIME.
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
WHERE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND TO DO
SOMETHING THAT BRINGS?
CALMNESS AS PEOPLE -- COME TO
THE END OF THEIR LIFE.
DUE TO AN ILLNESS.
SO THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
SON STORY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
HIM INTO THIS ROOM.
THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
I AM SHOCKED BY THE COMMENTS OF
THAT WERE JUST MADE ABOUT ICE
ENFORCEMENT.
AGENTS AT HOSPITALS AND SAN
DIEGO INTIMIDATING THAT ONLY
PATIENTS BUT ALSO STAFF.
I THINK THAT'S A LARGER
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD -- AND
WHILE THEY'RE OUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN -- FEDERAL REGULATIONS
SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CANNABIS IN OUR HOSPITALS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT'S
ALSO VERY REAL.
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
A POLICY COMMITTEE.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW THIS
WILL IMPACT PEOPLE'S LIVES HOW I
CAN ALLEVIATE PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
HOW WE TREAT.
THOSE WITH SEVERE ILLNESSES AT
THE END OF THE DAY WITH
COMPASSION SO YOU HAVE MY FULL
SUPPORT ON THIS AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO TO FIGURING OUT THE DETAILS
AS WE MOVE ALONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
MS CURRIE.
RENTS ARE YOU DID THAT WAS WAS
CREEL MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
BECAUSE WITH THE SAME ANYWAY --
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR AND MISTER
BARTEL FOR BRING IN THE BILL FOR
IT.
IN HONOR OF I'M STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL I'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR --
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO BE DONE PARTICULAR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BILL WE NEED TO KEEP
IT MOVING.
MADE ON RYAN MR TELL FAMILY AND
WE NEED TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER BARTEL.
WE APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DID TODAY
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO BOTH OF
YOU -- I KNOW WE HAD A
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY AND I
WILL ADMIT THAT -- AFTER THE
CONVERSATION I IT STARTED ME ON
A PATH OF THINKING I I WAS WAIT.
A BIT LAST NIGHT.
THINKING ABOUT THIS REMEMBER IN --
WATCHING -- TO CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS DIE OF CANCER -- AND
BEING THERE WHEN THEY DIED -- IT
WAS NOT PRETTY.
IT WAS NOT IT WAS NOT IT WAS
MANY YEARS AGO -- AND BEFORE
REALLY EVEN MEDICAL CANNABIS WAS --
SOMETHING THAT IS WAS EVEN
ACCEPTED IN CALIFORNIA -- I'VE
BEEN A STRONG PROPONENT OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS INDEED WAS ONE
THE FIRST THINGS I START TO WORK
ON WHEN I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- NEARLY FIVE YEARS
AGO -- MY CONCERNS WERE -- ABOUT --
THE POSSIBILITY THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COULD COME IN AND AND
THE FACT.
HOSPITAL OPERATIONS SHOULD THEY
CHOOSE TO DO THAT -- I BELIEVE
THAT -- WHILE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
NOT EXACTLY WHAT YOU MIGHT BE
LOOKING.
FOR I THINK THAT THAT IS HELPFUL
BUT I WILL SAY THAT I WILL
REMAIN OPEN OPEN. TO AMENDMENT
SHOULD WE FIND A WAY THAT
CLARIFIES TO STRENGTHEN
STRENGTHEN THIS -- IN IN SOME
WAY GOING FORWARD -- AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT NORMALLY WAY WE DO
THAT BUT I WANT TO ASSURE YOU IF
THERE'S THERE'S ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION COMES FORWARD.
I WOULD BE OPEN TO DISCUSSING
THAT AS AS AS THE BILL CONTINUES
TO MOVE -- IT IS -- ALMOST IT
REALLY AT THIS DAY AND AGE IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT WE CANNOT
PROVIDE THIS FOR SOMEONE IN NEED --
SO THEY CAN SPEND THE QUALITY
TIME THEY DESERVE WITH THEIR
FAMILY -- BEFORE -- DAY
ALTERNATELY PASS AND SO -- THANK
YOU FOR BRING THIS BOARD I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT JOURNEY
FOR FOR YOU -- AND AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL --
AND I TOO WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD HAVE
ME -- WHEN THE BELIEVES -- WHICH
I CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE OF THOSE
COMMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT -- YOU KNOW I I I THINK
ULTIMATELY.
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO ARGUE
WHEREVER YOU'RE YOU'RE CITY IN
THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BRING.
RELIEF TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE SUFFERING.
AND I THINK THIS FOR THAT REASON
THIS THIS LAW IS REVOLUTIONARY
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE ON OF
YOU KNOW FIGHTING THAT FIGHT
THAT THIS IS REALLY INTENDED TO
HELP PEOPLE.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU I I THINK
YOU'RE THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU
HELP WITH THERE IS IT IS IT'S
GOING TO BE AN ENORMOUS HELP. TO
TOWARD IMPLEMENTING THE BILL
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
COOPERATION OF THE HEALTH
FACILITIES THAT PROVIDE THAT
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT THEY ARE COOPERATIVE IN
THIS PROCESS AND THEY UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
ANYTHING OTHER THAN HELPING
PEOPLE.
THE THE THE LAWS ARE CHANGING
THE COUNTRY'S CHANGING BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SUBSTANCES
IS CHANGING AND NOW.
THERE ARE IS EVEN EVIDENCE --
SHOWING THAT IT CAN HELP.
NOT ONLY RELIEVE PAIN BUT ALSO --
OF REVERSE CERTAIN CONDITIONS
AND THAT THAT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE LEARNED
THROUGHOUT TIME AS WE AS WE
APPLY THIS.
HAVE FOR THE BENEFIT OF PEOPLE'S
HEALTH.
OF LASTING ONS FOR IS THE CO
AUTHOR SHIPS -- SENATOR BRIAN
JONES HAS ALSO BEEN A VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS MEASURE
HE'S IN THE AUDIENCES HE READ
YOU REMINDED ME THAT HE'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED.
AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL SO FOR
MAKING AMENDMENTS I'D LIKE TO
ALSO INCLUDE HIM.
IN THAT AND SIMPLY -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL OF THIS PANEL FOR
GIVING US YOUR UNDIVIDED
ATTENTION.
AND YOUR TIME AND AND GIVING
THIS BILL YOUR CONSIDERATION.
LOVE TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER PATEL -- MA'AM
SECRETARY -- WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY.
MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY MISTAKE
YOUR CURRY THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD I'D MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ON MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WATER.
NINE GIVE TEN VOTES THAT THANKS
HAVE TRAINED MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE WE HAD A OF SPECIAL --
ORDER BUSINESS AT TWO O'CLOCK
SENATOR ALLEN IS FASHIONABLY
LATE THAT'S OKAY WE WILL ACCEPT
THAT I UNDERSTAND YOU WERE IN
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY.
I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF -- I
REALLY DO APOLOGIZE I I PROMISE
YOU I WAS THERE I WAS THE VERY
FIRST PERSON OF PRESENT IN
PRIVACY COMMITTEE AND CANCER
HERE SO.
AB THANK YOU FOR YOUR WE ARE AND
THAT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR FOR
YOUR YOUR PATIENCE.
I'M.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE I I I THINK
YOU'LL UNDERSTAND WHY.
BY THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE IN NY.
I REALLY DO PERSON YOU.
ARE YOU WAITING FOR US AT THIS
IS A SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND IT'S BASED ON LAWS
IN SIX OTHER STATES -- A
PROHIBITS THE USE OF NATURAL
LATEX GLOVES IN RESTAURANTS
OTHER FOOD FACILITIES AND LET ME
TELL YOU WHY -- OKAY I WE GOT
INTO INCIDENTS OF LATEX INJURIES
INCREASING -- YOU KNOW -- YOU'LL
HEAR FROM OUR OUR OUR OUR
WITNESSES AS TO WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT THEM -- THERE ARE MUCH
BETTER ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE
THEY'RE LESS EXPENSIVE -- THIS
BILL PASSED WITH A THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO VOTE IN THE SENATE AND
THEY'RE ONLY THIRTY EIGHT
MEMBERS OF THE TIME -- AND SO
PLEASE DO GIVE US YOUR SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION I'D LOVE TO HEAR
FROM OUR WITNESSES WE HAVE
DOCTOR TRAVIS MILLER'S ANALOGIES
FROM SACRAMENTO.
OLIVER LEE ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER TO MY ATTENTION --
SO WE HAVE TO WITNESSES AND
THREE MINUTES EACH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS TRAVIS
MILLER I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
ALLERGIST TO PRACTICES HERE IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
I'VE BEEN HERE IN PRACTICE FOR
ALMOST FOURTEEN YEARS.
ON A DAILY BASIS I TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS WHO HAVE SEVERE
ALLERGIES INCLUDING LATEX
ALLERGIES I CONSIDER THIS -- A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS ACTUALLY.
LATEX ALLERGY IS -- QUITE
PRESENT IN THE COMMUNITY --
YOU'LL HEAR FROM A YOUNG PERSON
LIKE ALL OVER -- THAT LATEX
ALLERGY IS EXTREMELY -- SCARY --
IT'S TOTALLY LIFE ALTERING AND
WHEN IT AFFECTS SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS EATING -- IT'S HAS AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF THESE PATIENTS.
STATISTICALLY SPEAKING LATEX
ALLERGY CAN AFFECT. 6% OF THE
POPULATION THERE'S A SPECTRUM OF
SYMPTOMS CERTAINLY ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTIONS WHICH ARE POTENTIALLY
LIFE THREATENING -- ALLERGIC ARE --
AFFECTED BY THEM -- EPINEPHRINE
AS IT STANDS IS CURRENTLY THE
ONLY TREATMENT FOR LATEX ALLERGY
SHORT OF AVOIDANCE -- WE
ENCOURAGE -- PATIENTS TO TRY AND
AVOID LATEX BUT OBVIOUSLY IF
THEY'RE IN A RESTAURANT OR
ANOTHER SETTING WHERE THEY'RE
EATING SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE --
ACTIVITY OF DAILY LIVING WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD BE
SAFE -- I WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS OLIVER LEE AND I'M A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD COLLEGE
STUDENT. THREE YEARS AGO WITHOUT
WARNING I DEVELOPED A LIFE
THREATENING LATEX ALLERGY THIS
ALLERGY HAS AFFECTED EVERY
ASPECT OF MY LIFE.
A LATEX BALLOON POPPED IN A
CONFINED CLASSROOMS SPREAD LATEX
PROTEINS THAT CAUSE ME TO
IMMEDIATELY GOING TO ANAPHYLAXIS.
I THEN DECIDED TO EDUCATE MYSELF
MAKE POSITIVE CHANGES FOR OTHERS
AS WELL.
I CONSTANTLY WORRY ABOUT STAYING
ALIVE BUT WHEN AVOIDANCE ISN'T
POSSIBLE I KNOW THAT I ALWAYS
CARRY MY RESCUE MEDICATION.
WITH ME AT ALL TIMES.
LATEX EXPOSURES CAN BE EVOKED
SIMPLY BY INHALING AIRBORNE
PROTEINS ARE INGESTINGANYTHING
TOUCHED BY LATEX GLOVES
INVISIBLE LATEX PROTEINS STICK
TO OBJECTS FOOD AND SCANNED.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN A BILL TO
BAN LATEX FROM FOOD SERVICE WAS
PASSED IN THE STATE OF
CONNECTICUT DURING TESTIMONY A
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVE.
OF CONNECTICUT A BOARD CERTIFIED
ALLERGIST ASKED MEMBERS OF THE
MALAYSIAN LATEX PROMOTION
COUNCIL ONE SIMPLE QUESTION.
IF I AM ALLERGIC TO LATEX AM I
SAFE WITH ANY OF YOUR LATEX
GLOVES.
THEIR ANSWER WAS NOW.
A SINGLE LATEX PROTEIN CAN BE
LIFE THREATENING FOR US PLEASE
ENSURE THAT OUR CITIZENS AND
VISITORS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
FOOD.
LET'S PROTECT THOSE WHO WORK IN
OUR FOOD INDUSTRY FROM
DEVELOPING THIS TRULY
DEVASTATING ALLERGY.
A LATEX PROTEIN IS A PROTEIN AND
IS HIGHLY ALLERGENIC LOW PROTEIN
LATEX GLOVES ARE NOT SAFE.
THEIR GLOVES ARE DEADLY THANK
YOU FOR YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
SB.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT -- JUST.
WE HAD TO WITNESSES SOME SORRY.
DO YOU.
WANT TO SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY
JUSTICE.
YEAH YEAH THIS OKAY SUPER SUPER
QUICK.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KRISTEN SHE
AND I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU THAT.
KNOW THAT MY SISTER CARA AND I
BOTH DEVELOP LATEX.
ALLERGY.
AND SHE DEVELOPED IT SO BADLY
THAT SHE ACTUALLY PASSED AWAY
FROM THIS ALLERGY FROM TOUCHING
LATEX GLOVES THAT WAS MADE BY
FOOD.
UP SORRY THE FOOD IS MADE BY
LATEX GLOVES AND SHE PASSED AWAY
IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SHE COULD
NOT EAT.
SHE WAS AIRBORNE I'M SORRY I'M
NOT GOING I'M GOING UP MY SCRIPT
SOMEWHERE ONLY ONE MAKE THIS
QUICK.
AND I HAD TO BURY MY SISTER AND
I JUST WANT THE NEXT GENERATION
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND MY
CHILDREN. TO NOT VERY ME BUT
ALSO FOR THEM TO BE SAFER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR HELPING ME CALIFORNIA SAFER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT AND AND JUST YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT.
ONE MY NAME IS SHERRY WHARTON
FROM EUREKA CALIFORNIA I WAS
FOUND DOWN UNCONSCIOUS IN A
LOCAL RESTAURANT FROM SOUTH MAY
WITH LATEX ALLERGY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB SIX SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU.
AND THEN THANK YOU IN JUST YOUR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE PLEASE.
MY NAME IS LIANA SHEEN I SUPPORT
THIS PHONE FROM SANTA BARBARA.
AND MY AUNT PASSED AWAY FROM.
THESE GLOVES THESE GLOVES ARE
DEADLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DEVELOPED
THIS ALLERGY WORKING IN FOOD
SERVICE USING LATEX GLOVES.
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MRS NEVER ATTAINED I
DEVELOPED THIS ALLERGY AT THE
AGE OF A AND I SUPPORT -- SB.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN ONCE AGAIN JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION PLEASE MY
NAME IS SEAN FLICKINGER FROM SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SERRA FLICK INJURE I
HAVE THIS ALLERGY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH PETANI
PROUD MOTHER OF ALL OVERLY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN THANK YOU.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- I'M SO SORRY VERY
TAKE INTENTIONALLY -- I'M SORRY
HANG ON HANG ON I'M SORRY WE BUT
ARE THESE ARE NAMES.
ADDITIONALLY JUST ONE ONE NAME
OKAY AND SUPPORT.
SB [inaudible]
SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KHAN DONAHOE AND
MY SON AND I BOTH HAVE THE LATEX
ALLERGY AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
SO THAT WE CAN BE SAFE WHILE WE
EAT.
ALRP LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH SCOTT FROM
SACRAMENTO I REPRESENT AND THE
FOUNDER OF A LARGE SUPPORT GROUP
THE NO ATEX SUPPORT GROUP WITH
OVER ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS.
ALL SEVERELY ALLERGIC TO LATEX.
I AM SEVERELY ALLERGIC AND HAVE
ALMOST DIED THANK YOU FROM THANK
YOU LETTERS CONTAMINATION FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MIKE MARLIN I LIVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND HAS BEEN A
DIVERSE CONDOM A LATEX COP.
AND I'VE NEARLY HAD TO PULL OR
OR HAVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
OF COLOR OF RESTAURANTS IN ORDER
FOR HER NOT TO DIE FROM LATEX OR
SUPPORTER THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I MEAN OPPOSITION.
OKAY OKAY I BELIEVE WE HAD DID
WE HAVE.
DO WE HAVE PEOPLE AND BE ABLE
THIS IS.
HANG ON JUST A SEC TO HAVE
PEOPLE CALLING IN.
PLEASE THERE'S A DIFFERENT
SUPPORT.
PAM WAS HAVE SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH
YOU'RE NOW.
OR RECALL AND PRIVATE PERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE ONE
OKAY [inaudible]
THE THE
HELLO.
LOOKING ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS THIS WORTH
SYMINGTON.
SIMON TEN YES.
OKAY YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO STATE
YOUR POSITION FOR SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. THREE FIVE AND TEN
AND I FROM.
KANSAS AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY.
BACK UP -- OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M BILL BRIGHT RECKON
I REPRESENT.
THEM THE MALAYSIAN RUBBER EXPORT
PROMOTION COUNCIL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON SENATE BILL SIX SEVEN
SEVEN AND SUGGEST AN ALTERNATIVE.
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF LATEX
ADVANCEMENT AND HEALTH BENEFITS
WE'LL SHOW THAT THE PROHIBITION
OF ALL LATEX GLOVES IS ON
WARRANTED.
THE PREMISE UPON WHICH THE
LEGISLATION WAS FOUNDED.
FOUNDED IT'S GROUNDS FOR THE
PROPOSED PHASE OUT MUST BE RE
EXAMINED AND UPDATED TO EXCLUDE
POWDER FREE LOW PROTEIN LATEX
GLOVES FROM THE PROVISION.
IT IS OF UTMOST CONCERN TO
PROTECT CLUB USERS AND FOOD
CONSUMERS IN THE FOOD INDUSTRY.
LATEX GRUBS USED IN THE FOOD
INDUSTRY PROTECT AGAINST THE
TRANSMISSION OF CONTAMINANTS
FROM BOTH USERS AND CONSUMERS.
AS SHOWN BY STUDIES TIME AGAIN
MODERN POWDER FREE LOW PROTEIN
LATEX GLOVES PROVIDE SUPERIOR.
A BARRIER PROTECTION AND HAVE A
HIGH RESISTANCE TO TERRY.
LATEX GLOVES CAN ALSO RESEAL
AFTER A SMALL PUNCTURE UNLIKE
OTHER CLUBS.
THEY ARE STILL WIDELY USED IN
THE FOOD INDUSTRY AND IN THE
PERFORMANCE OF SURGICAL AND
MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
LOW PROTEIN POWDER FREE LAKE SEX
CLUBS ARE RECOMMENDED BY THE FDA.
BY NINE AT NIGHT NOW I US BY
OSHA.
AND IN FACT THE THE ASTHMA AND
ELDERLY FOR FOUNDATION SET FINDS
THAT ONLY ABOUT 1% OF US ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THESE ALLERGIES.
MOREOVER THE FDA STATED THAT THE
DATA LINKING.
LATEX PROTEINS AND FOODS FOR
ALLERGENIC REACTION IS BASED ON
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE AND IS VERY
WEAK.
MOREOVER THERE ARE NO REPORTED
DEATHS CAUSED BY LATEX PROTEIN
ALLERGIES BLACK THROUGH FOOD
INGESTION.
FTA ALSO PERMITS LOW PROTEIN
POWDER FREE GLOVES IN MEDICAL
SETTINGS.
THE LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSED
PROHIBITION OF ALL LATEX GLOVES
WILL OPEN THE MARKET TO THE USE
OF ALTERNATIVE SYNTHETIC GLOVES.
WHICH POSE HEALTH-MATTERS
THEMSELVES SOME GLOVES LIKE
FINAL CAN LEACH OUT HIGHLY TOXIC
CHEMICALS USED DURING THEIR
MANUFACTURING PROJECT.
PROCESS.
IN SUMMARY LOW PROTEIN POWDER
FREE GLOVES AT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE MEANS OF BARRY
PROTECTION FOR GLOVE USERS IN
MEDICAL AND FOOD INDUSTRIES.
AGAIN THE FDA HAS STATED THAT
THE DATA LINKING LATEX PROTEINS
IN FOODS TO ALLERGENIC REACTIONS
IS BASED ON ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
WE HAVE PROVIDED -- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH UP
SUBSTITUTE AMENDMENT WHICH WOULD
OUT LAW.
HI POWDER GLOVES THE GLOVES THAT
CAUSED THE PROBLEM.
AND PLUS THE PROBLEM IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES.
BUT WOULD ALLOW THE CONTINUATION
OF THE GLOVES THAT ARE LOW
POWERED AND HAVE HAD MUCH MORE
SUCCESS.
IN.
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM HAVING
THE ALLERGIES.
THE THE THING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES ON THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
FOR I TO SUFFER FROM LATEX
ALLERGIES AND I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION TALKED ABOUT -- NOR
PERFORMS TYPE OF GLOVES TALKS
ABOUT VINYL WILL WORKING THAT
YOU MISS -- ARENA FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS SAYS EMT.
AND POLY OVER TEN YEARS AGO THEY
SWITCH FROM THE LATEX TO VINYL
GLOVES.
AND I FOUND THE VINYL GLOVES
WERE A LOT BETTER AT PROTECTING
US FROM BODY FLUIDS THAN.
ON THE LATEX GLOVES.
SO WITH THAT SAID -- I THINK THE
LATEX GLOVES ARE BETTER AND THAT
WE HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN
PLACE TO PROTECT THOSE FROM
LATEX ALLERGIES OR SOMETHING.
BENEFICIAL TO THE FOLKS OUT
THERE THAT SUFFER FROM LATEX
ALLERGIES BECAUSE IT IS AN ISSUE.
AND I PROBABLY BIGGER THAN AND
BIGGER THAN MORE REALLY THINK
REALIZE OUT THERE.
SO.
FOR I GUESS SOME MEDICAL
AGENCIES FROM PARTICULAR MY CASE
EMS AGENCIES WORKING.
AND USING SWITCHING THE GLOVES
FROM A LATEX THE FINAL SHOULD BE
TELLING US SOMETHING THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING OUT THERE
BECAUSE A LOT OF FOR FOR
SPONSORS WERE EVEN HAVING THE
ALLERGIES TO THE LATEX GLOVES
JUST WORN FOR SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
SO WHAT THAT SO LOOKING FOR TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THINKING.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
MISTER MISTER.
THANK YOU I WANNA AND THINKING
SHE FROM COMING FROM THE
DISTRICT TO AND TALKING ABOUT
THIS I KNOW YOU'VE ALSO BEEN
ACTIVE IN THE DISTRICT -- IN
SANTA BARBARA TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND I THINK AS WE HAVE
HEARD THAT -- YOU KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE SEVERE AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
FOLKS HEALTHY AND AVOID THE
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE OF THE BILL DOES
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND AND AND AND ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU -- WE HAD
TO WE NEED A MOTION WE HAVE.
THE MOTION BY MISTER FLORA
SECOND BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY.
SECRETARY OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT.
WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LARA I LIVE ON THE MOON I
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA.
RAMOS RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
YOUR BILL HAS TO GO TO
SUBCOMMITTEE THIRTY MEMBERS OVER
MIGHT BE THE RELIGION FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON CENTER MONIES POSSIBLE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- RECENTLY INSURERS
HAVE BEGAN ADDING NON MEDICAL
INNOVATIVE BENEFITS TO THE MOST
POPULAR MEDIGAP PACKAGES IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DISTINGUISH THEIR
PRODUCTS FROM OTHERS IN THE
MARKET PLACE.
OF THESE BENEFITS INCLUDING
VISION DENTAL AND HEARING TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL COVERAGE
THE INCLUSION OF THESE NON
STANDARD BENEFITS INSIDE THE
STANDARD MEDIGAP PACKAGE HINDER
THE ABILITY OF CONSUMERS. TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL COMPARISONS
BETWEEN NON MEDICAL BENEFITS DUE
TO THE VARIATION OFFERED BY
INSURERS SENATE BILL FOUR ZERO
SEVEN EXPANDS THE OPEN
ENROLLMENT PERIOD. FOR MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PLANS TO A MINIMUM
OF SIXTY DAYS REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
TO COLLABORATE WITH SPECIFIED IN
CITIES. TO DEVELOP A DISPLAY
STANDARDIZATION OF INNOVATIVE
PLANS IN MANDATES INSURERS TO
NOTIFY AN ENROLLEE OF HIS OR HER
OPEN ENROLLMENT RATES.
THIS BILL SETS CONSUMER FOCUSED
REGULATIONS WHICH WILL ALLOW
SENIORS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND ALL
ASPECTS OF AN INNOVATIVE PLAN.
THEY MAY SEEK TO PURCHASE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- OTHERS
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEE KNOWN AS THEIR OPPOSITION TO
SENATOR MONIES BILL -- JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ELECTED
THINK THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS
AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE BILL.
WE DO TECHNICALLY HAVE -- POSE --
POSITION ON THE BILL RIGHT NOW
BUT WE THINK THAT WHERE THE BILL
IS RIGHT NOW WE ONLY HAVE A FEW
TECHNICAL TWO WEEKS TO GET DONE
OR CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN GET
THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
AND AND THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
ON A SOME PRIEST AMENDMENTS.
GREATLY IMPROVE THE BILL AND WE
DO HAVE SOME TECHNICAL CHANGES
AND MORE LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE
OUR DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
SEVENTY WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE TWO WOULD LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR WE'VE HAD EXTREMELY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WERE
HOPEFUL THAT GOING FORWARD WILL
BE ABLE TO REMEMBER OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. TO KNOW WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NO -- ONE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND I'M SORRY JUST MISS A
MUCH FROM HIS CARILLO.
THE SECOND BY THE TAKE YOUR
CURRY -- THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WHICH I TO
CLOSE CENTER JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK HERE I VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AND YOU ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
YES YES THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA ISLA MOOD.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOU HAVE TEN VOTES YOUR BILL IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MOVE THE BILL.
WELCOME WELCOME SENATOR.
EVEN THAT RESPONSE I WILL MOVE
QUICKLY [inaudible]
I HAVE. ONE SINGLE POINT OF VIEW.
THAT INFORMS MY THINKING.
IN PROPOSING HI PATTY
[inaudible]
THIS MEASURE.
WHEN THERE'S AN EMERGENCY?
AND YOUR DISPATCHING AMBULANCES.
WHO DO YOU TRUST?
YOU TRUST PRIVATE COMPANIES AND
I KNOW THERE'S OFTEN THESE KINDS
OF CHALLENGES BUT THIS IS A
DEEPER AND MORE IMPORTANT ISSUE
OR DO YOU TRUST WHAT YOU SEE IN
THIS ROOM.
LITERALLY A THOUSAND YEARS OF
PROFESSIONALS WITH THE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE FIRE CHIEF
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR TESTIFYING
THESE ARE PEOPLE ON THE
FRONTLINE TO MAKE THE DECISION
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO WERE
INFORMED THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
UNDERSTAND THE RISK AND THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO I'M FIGHTING FOR
WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL TO
GIVE THEIR PROFESSIONAL.
EXPERTISE VOICE IN DETERMINING
HIS DISPATCHER WILL TURN THIS
MATTER QUICKLY BECAUSE I RESPECT
THOSE TO MOTIONS WITH MOTION
SECOND. TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN ON A REAL
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIAN RICE
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
I'M A THIRTY ONE YEAR VETERAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE SERVICE IN
SERVE BOTH ON THE FRONT LINES
AND AS A DEPUTY CHIEF FOR THE
SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
THE MOST SACRED MISSION OF
GOVERNMENT AT ANYLEVEL IS
PROTECTING THE LIVES AND HEALTH
OF ITS PEOPLE. FOR MORE THAN
SEVEN DECADES THAT MISSION HAS
INCLUDED PROVIDING FAST
EFFECTIVE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE RESPONSE THE FIRST AND
OFTEN MOST CRITICAL LIFE AND
DEATH RESPONSIBILITY IS A NINE
ONE ONE DISPATCH.
WHEN SECONDS COUNT IT'S A SWORN
DUTY OF THE PUBLIC OF PUBLIC
FIRE AGENCIES TO DEPLOY?
THE CLOSEST AND FASTEST
RESOURCES POSSIBLE.
THEY'RE THE MOST DIRECT AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO PUBLIC SAFETY
PROVIDERS.
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY EIGHT
INSURES THAT THIS SACRED
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT PASSED OFF.
OR COMPROMISE BY MOTIVATIONS
OTHER THAN WHAT MATTERS MOST IN
THAT'S PATIENT CARE AND THE
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
UNDER SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
PUBLIC AGENCIES WILL BE
PREVENTED FROM DIRECTLY
OUTSOURCING THIS CORE PUBLIC
SAFETY FUNCTION TO A PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT ENTITY.
THOSE AGREEMENTS THAT EXIST
TODAY ARE PROTECTED BY THIS
MEASURE.
IN RECOGNIZING THE CORE MISSION
OF PUBLIC SAFETY SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT DEMANDS THE HIGHEST
STANDARD OF RESPONSE FROM PUBLIC
AGENCIES WHILE ALSO REQUIRING
ADHERENCE TO THE COUNTY'S
MEDICAL CONTROL.
AFTER ALL THE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC IN THE TAXPAYERS TO WHOM
THEY SERVE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE MISSION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES MEDICAL
DECISIONS ARE NOT BASED ON COST
OR PROFIT.
OTHER THE URGENT NEEDS OF THE
PATIENT.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT SIMPLY
RECOGNIZES THAT THESE
ACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC AGENCIES MUST
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR DISPATCH
IN RESPONSE MODE THAT BEST
PROTECTS THEIR COMMUNITIES.
EVERY DISPATCH IN RESOURCE MODE
MUST ALWAYS MEET OR EXCEED LAMPS --
MEDICAL CONTROL POLICIES.
AS FIREFIGHTERS CMS IS PART OF
OUR CORE FUNCTION YOU SIMPLY
DON'T WORK AS A FIREFIGHTER IN
THIS STATE IF YOU WEREN'T AT
LEAST AN EMT.
IN LIFE OR DEATH SITUATIONS IT'S
ALL ABOUT DEPLOYING A RAPID
RESPONSE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LOCAL AGENCIES FOR MAKING THAT
HAPPEN SHOULD NOT BE CHECKED OFF
ON ANYBODY'S BOTTOM LINE.
ON BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL.
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMTS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WHAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR DAVID VAN
STRELA AND I'M A PHYSICIAN WITH
FORTY SEVEN YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
THE IN THIS FIELD.
I HAVE SERVED AS AN EMS AGENCY
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AUTHORED
ARTICLES AND WORKED AS A
LECTURER AND EDUCATOR ON EMS
RELATED ISSUES.
I'M HERE AS AN EMS PROFESSIONAL
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT BEEN RACED.
AS MISTER RICE IS INDICATED AS
THE FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE CLOSEST EMS
UNITS RESPOND TO NINE ONE ONE
CALLS.
AS MENTIONED THE MAJOR THRUST OF
THIS BILL IS TO IMPROVE
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION
PROCEDURES AND QUICKLY RESPOND
TO ANY PERSON CALLING. NINE ONE
ONE TO PREVENT INTERFERENCE WITH
A PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
AUTHORITY TO DIRECTLY RECEIVING
PROCESS REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE
ORIGINATING WITHIN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES TERRITORIAL
JURISDICTION. TO THE EMERGENCY
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
THE KEY FEATURE OF THIS BILL IS
TO ENSURE THAT A PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCY RETAIN CONTROL OVER THE
FLOW OF CONSEQUENTIAL
INFORMATION PER PERSON CALLING.
NINE ONE ONE THROUGH THE TEST
DISPATCH CENTER TO THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM.
THE ROLE OF INFORMATION AND
MAKING SYSTEM SAFE IS PROFOUND.
NOT ONLY IS INFORMATION FLOW A
PRIME VARIABLE IN CREATING
SAFETY.
BUT IT IS ALSO AN INDICATOR OF
SYSTEM FUNCTIONING.
DISCUSSIONS OF MEDICAL CONTROL.
I AGREE THAT PHYSICIAN OVERSIGHT
AND THE DELEGATION MEDICAL
SERVICES TO PARAMEDICS IS
IMPORTANT AND SHOULD BE ASSURED
THROUGH MEDICAL CONTROL.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SHOULD RETAIN THE
BENEFIT OF DECIDING THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE SUITABLE TO THEIR NEEDS.
THE INTEREST FROM THE COMMUNITY
ARE DISTINCT FROM MEDICAL
CONTROL.
A WELL INTEGRATED SYSTEM
COMPRISING A REQUISITE VARIETY
OF ENTITIES SUPPORTS RELIABILITY
SAFETY IN THE SITUATIONS WHERE
THE OUT LIAR IS TO RIDLEY
DISREGARDED AS RANDOM
INDEPENDENT INFORMATION.
SOME OUT LIARS ARE EARLY HERALDS
PROCESSES THE CASCADE FAILURE
AND DEATH.
THE MS AGENCY PROVIDES MEDICAL
CONTROL AND EFFECTIVE DELEGATION
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR THE
SITUATIONS.
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES PROVIDE
EXPERTISE IN PROTECTING CITIZENS
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY DETERMINES
THE LEVEL OF SERVICE NECESSARY
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY WELL BEING.
THE DISPATCHERS INTEGRATED AND
EMS CAN BEST SUPPORT THE MISSION
WITH UNIMPEDED INFORMATION FLOW.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT ADDRESSES
SITUATIONS WHERE THE FLOOR.
WITH THE FLOW OF INFORMATION TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES DELAYED
OR WITH HELD ON THE MISTAKEN
BELIEF THAT COMMUNITIES CHOSEN
SERVICE LEVELS ARE MATTER OF
LANCE'S.
MEDICAL CONTROL WHEN A COUNTY
DISPATCH SYSTEM IS NOT
INTEGRATED INTO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES IN A SYSTEM.
CONSEQUENTIAL DISPATCH
INFORMATION ISN'T BEING SHARED
WITH ALL UNITS FIGHTERS THE SAME
TIME.
HOUSING AS THE FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
RECOGNIZES THE NECESSITY OF
MEDICAL CONTROL.
REPRESENTS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY BY
HARMONIZING MEDICAL CONTROL WITH
THE MISSION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON.
YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
TAMERA HIM AT IT THANK YOU FOR
TAMARI MINUTES ANAHEIM WHITE
HOUSE RESIDENTIAL DETOX AND
TREATMENT CENTER FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE STRONGLY SUPPORT -- THIS
BILL AND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK
YOU.
MISSY JOBS WITH NELSON MARKS
MORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI SHERIN GUNS ALL THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST CONTRA COSTA
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT IN THE
CITIES OF DANIEL TULARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROSANNA CAMACHO HERE
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MICHAEL GLOBULIN IT FOR HERE IN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL AND
FIRE CHIEFS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE AFTERNOON STEVE KOVACS FIRE
CHIEF SCOTTS VALLEY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND
PRESIDENT OF ARTIST SUFFICIENT
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
STEPHEN REA FIRE CHIEF WATER
MODIFIER DISTRICTS AND WORKING
COUNTING.
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
TODD MATTHEWS PRESIDENT
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX REPRESENTING DEPARTMENTS IN
SOLANO AND NAPA COUNTY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF TWENTY
FIREFIGHTERS ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN JOHNSON THE
STOCKTON FIRE DEPARTMENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORIARTY A PRESIDENT'S TALKING
FAR FAR SO SHE XIN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RODRIGUEZ
REPRESENTED ME COUNTY FARGE C.
SO SHE XIN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REAGAN LIKE FIRE
CHIEF ON TERRIO FIRE DEPARTMENT
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DIRECTLY WITH THE A CITY
BELLWOOD PART OF HABIT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RODRIGUEZ FIRE CHIEF CITY OF
FULL SOME STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JEFF RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRIAN YOU WHERE POLICE CHIEF
CITY OF SOUTH LAKE TAHOE ALSO
OVERSEEING AND NINE ONE CENTER
THIS REGIONAL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LERI RECALL THE
RIBS OF THE COSTA MESA FIRE AND
RESCUE DEPARTMENT AND ALSO THE
SENATE BACK COLLEGE PARAMEDIC
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF BOILS
ASSISTANT FIRE CHIEF ON BEHALF
OF THE NEWPORT BEACH FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND THE ORANGE COUNTY
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
STEM OPENED FIRE CHIEF CITY
REDWOOD CITY AND PRESIDENT OF
SAN MATEO COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JEFF FAULT IN THE PARTY WITH A
COMMA FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
IN VICE PRESIDENT CEMETERY
COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LANCE CAULKINS AREAS SEVEN
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA BARGE USES A
SOLUTION REQUESTING STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CRESCENTA FOR CONSUMERS VICE
PRESIDENT SACRAMENTO AREA
FIREFIGHTERS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHOI VERY DEPUTY FIRE CHIEF
CONCERN AS FAR DEPARTMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL
AS THE OPERATIONS SECTION CAL
CHIEFS A STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RARE MERS REPRESENT COUNTY FIRE
CHIEF SEEN HIM AS SECTION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVE JULY THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT FIRE CAPTAIN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KEVIN WILD INTER COUNTY FIRE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT NAY FOR KIRK CITY REDLANDS
FIRE CHIEF STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RECESS THEIR DEPUTY FELONS FIRE
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SHOWN ROOMS IN A CITY FAR FARCE
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THREE TO LUIS WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JUSTIN LE GOSSIP TRACY
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARK DO OUR STOCKTON FIRE
DISPATCH STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RICK IS NOT BACK CITY VELLUM IN
A FIRE DEPARTMENT DEPUTY CHIEF
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEAN NEELY LATER MEDICAL FIRE
DISTRICT FIRE CHIEF AND ALSO THE
CHAIRMAN FOR THAT SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
REGIONAL FIRE DISPATCH STRONG
SUPPORT.
FIRE CAPTAIN GUILD RARE -- EAST
CONTRA COSTA FIRE.
VICE PRESIDENT UNITED
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS A
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY LOCAL TWELVE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ADAM DAMPIERRE EMS DIRECTOR FOR
SOUTH SOME LOOKING COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY QUESTION YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A DOG MCALLEN FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY ARENA.
AND ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANTHONY STEVENS VICE PRESIDENT
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FAR FAR AS
LOCAL TOOL THIRTY STRONG SUPPORT.
A DAVID GRAHAM ALL FIRED VISION
SHE SOUTH SO MAKING CALIFORNIA
TORY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHAU WOULD LATER MANTECA
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
TAG LEAVE FACT HAPPENED SOUTH
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY FIRE THIRTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA WELLING DIVISION CHIEF
MONTEREY COUNTY REGIONAL FIRE
DISTRICT REQUEST TRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THURMOND DUSKY LATER MANTECA
FIRE DISTRICT SEVENTY COUNTY
REGIONAL FIRE DISPATCH STORY
REQUESTING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ABOUT
THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS IN
SUPPORT OF THE TICKET.
STEVE OUT ALL MEN UNITED
FIREFIGHTERS OF LOS ANGELES CITY
LOCAL ONE TWELVE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RANDALL BRADLEY THE SOUTH SOME
LOOKING COUNTY FIRE -- DISTRICT
FIRE CHIEF AND STRONG SUPPORT
ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCE AND SOME LOOKING
COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
OTHERS SAY NO ONE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE
[inaudible]
STATE.
WE HAVE GOT GUTS AFTER THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN VERS
MICHELLE GIVENS -- ON BEHALF OF
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT TODAY AT
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
WENT INTO THOSE -- SHOULD THE
AUTHOR ACCEPT THEM ONCE THEY
GOING TO PRINT OUR ASSOCIATIONS
WILL RE EVALUATE AT IT IS BASED
ON OUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
EVALUATOR EXCEPT.
GREAT -- THERE ARE THERE IS ONE
OR THE AREA THAT'S OUTSTANDING
AROUND MEDICAL CONTROL THAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
AUTHORS AND SPONSORS AROUND --
AND WE COMMIT TO DOING SO I HAD
JUST AROUND TO AND IT AND I I DO
THINK THAT WE CAN COME TO
AGREEMENT SO IT'S OUR HOPE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
TROUT SORRY ON BEHALF OF LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION -- WE
AGREE WITH THE PROPOSED CHANGE --
THAT WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT
COUNTY LENSES I DO NOT HAVE THE
POWER TO DICTATE WHEN CITY.
FIRE DEPARTMENT FIRE JUST UNITS
ARE DISPATCHED -- RESPONSE TO A
NINE ONE ONE CALL WITHIN THEIR
OWN JURISDICTIONS.
HOWEVER WE ARE OPPOSE THE
PROVISION THAT WOULD PERMANENTLY --
BAR ANY LOCAL JURISDICTION THAT
DOES NOT HAVE AN EXISTING
CONTRACT -- FOR PRIVATE EMS
DISPATCH SERVICESFROM ENTERING
INTO SUCH AN AGREEMENT IN THE
FUTURE -- PRESIDENT OUT OF THE
IN PART IMPORTANT AS THIS
PROVISION -- WOULD NOT ONLY STE
LIMITLESS LIMITS THE FLEXIBILITY
TO PROVIDE -- YOU MISS RESOURCES
IN TIMES OF FINANCIAL DISTRESS --
BUT ALSO SAYS PRESIDENT AGAINST
FUTURE PUBLIC PRIVATE --
CONTRACTING OF ANY OTHER COUNTRY
OF ANY OTHER SERVICESTHAT MAY
BE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CITIES SO FOR THAT -- WHERE
PUZZLES MANY?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY TO FRESNO TULARE
MADERA THERE'S SOME PRETTY HIGH
FUNCTIONING -- SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT I DIDN'T HEAR
ANY CHEESE WHO SUPPORTED THE
BILL COME UP AND TAKE ISSUE WITH
AND I JUST APPRECIATE THE OFFICE
MADE SOME EFFORTS IN THAT REGARD --
BUT IF YOU THINK AND THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE IN THIS BILL TO TO
PROTECT THOSE HIGHER FUNCTIONING
SYSTEM TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
CLOSE TO JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
KAREN LYING ON THE OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND MENDOCINO
SHASTA SISKIYOU IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY ALL IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON UNDERESTIMATE AS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
PLACENTIA -- RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SO MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FARMING DATING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES HOW WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED OR OPPOSITION BUT
THE MINUTES TO LOOK AT HOWEVER
WE HAVE NOT ACCEPTED THEM BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
THANK YOU.
THERE VERGE ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
KRISTIN AWAY VOTE ON BEHALF OF
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE.
DR GIRL SHIELDS ON BEHALF OF THE
EMS MEDICAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
IN OPPOSITION BUT WILL BE
CLOSELY REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK IN WE HAVE
A SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
IN CENTER I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
FOR I THINK -- AS THOSE WELL
STATED BY AT THE SUPPORT HERE
THE REASONS WHY WE NEED TO
MAINTAIN THE TYPE OF SERVICE WE
HAVE.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN HERE WHO
HAVE CAME FROM DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE.
HAVE TALKED ABOUT WHAT THE JOB
THEY DO IN BY LITERALLY TAKING
IT OUT OF THEIR CONTROL TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
DEFINITELY BE PUTTING
CALIFORNIANS -- LIVES AT STAKE
SO THE OUTLOOK FOR DIAPERS TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL I JUST HAVE
ONE PROBLEM WITH YOUR BILL.
I WANT TO BE OUT AS COOPER JUST
DON'T WE CAN SUPPORT YOU KNOW I
TASTE SOMETHING THAT ALL THAT I
I GOT THESE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
HERE.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
LAST TIME I THOUGHT ABOUT BEING
A LEGISLATOR WHEN YOU TAKE
AMENDMENTS AND IT DOESN'T REMOVE
OPPOSITION YOU DON'T TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS BUT CERTAINLY I'D BE
HAPPY TO ADD YOU IN AS A CO
AUTHOR ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD
SO.
CHOOSE TO JOIN THIS IMPORTANT
ENTERPRISE.
THANK YOU THINK THANK YOU
SENATOR.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW IF I
COULD BRING TO THE ATTENTION IF
IT'S RELEVANT AT ALL I KNOW THAT
THERE IS OFTEN A CHALLENGE
BETWEEN THE HOUSES AND THE
CHALLENGE OF WHICH I HAVE NO.
TOLERANCE FOR BUT THE THE ARE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE AFTER
THE IMPRESSIVE PRESENTATION BY
THESE.
OF FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRE CHIEFS
AROUND THE STATE VOTED NINE TO
ZERO TO GET THIS BILL OUT I JUST
OFFER THAT AS A POINT OF VIEW TO
ADD TO YOUR CONSIDERATION.
POINT WELL TAKEN CENTER AND I
THINK THAT IS A CLOSE UP TO THAT
IS A NO -- FURTHER A QUESTIONS.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT IS ANYBODY
ALSO MY COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS BEFORE THE CENTER
CLOSES [inaudible]
THE FIGHT OF OF ASK ANYMORE
QUESTIONS.
SO -- THAT COULD HAPPEN THE BILL
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU SIR -- AND I THINK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS --
WE DO HAVE A MOTION -- BY A
MISTER RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY
MISTAKE YEAR CURRY.
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR I
THINK IT JUST IT I THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
MEADOW SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE GEAR
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
FLORA FLORA I LIVE ON MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
GET TEN VOTES WE HAVE FIVE
MINUTE MEMBERS NOT HERE AS MORE
THAN NINE REMEMBER THAT.
I'M GOOD THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR TRAVEL FROM
ALL OF THE CORNERS OF THE STATE
WE REALLY APPRECIATED THANKS FOR
GIVEN THE TIME TO ALL THE CHIEFS
AND MEMBERS THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION I ACTUALLY WAS GOING
TO MAKE A REQUEST FOR CENTER
HERTZBERG COME BACK IN PRESENT
MY BILL -- THIS IS SUCH A GREAT
JOB.
SENATE BILL -- FOUR FIFTY TWO IS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPTION PRESENT
TODAY -- TWENTY YEARS AGO AT A
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AT AGE.
THIRTY ONE I HEARD THOSE THREE
WORDS THAT NOBODY EVER WANTS TO
HEAR.
YOU HAVE CANCER.
AND I STILL REMEMBER THAT DAY AS
IF IT HAPPENED YESTERDAY IN THE
IMPACT.
THAT IT HAD ON ME PERSONALLY AND
OF COURSE -- COMMUNICATING THAT
TO MY WIFE I HAVING TO GO HOME.
WITH A SIX MONTH OLD SON.
A TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND A
FOUR YEAR OLD SON AND HAVING TO
COMMUNICATE.
THAT I'VE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER.
YEARS LATER -- WHEN I WAS
SERVING AS ANY SIMILAR MEMBER I
NEED A CONSTITUENT CAME FORWARD?
WITH A STORY ABOUT BEING
CONTACTED BY A RESEARCHER BEFORE
SHE HAD EVEN DECIDED TO TELL HER
FAMILY ABOUT HER DIAGNOSIS OF
CANCER -- FOR WHATEVER REASON
THIS CONSTITUENT HAD DECIDED TO
KEEP HER DIAGNOSIS -- PERSONAL
TERCEL SHE HADN'T EVEN TOLD HER
MOM -- THE SHE HAD CANCER.
AND WHEN SHE WAS CONTACTED BY A
RESEARCHER OUT OF THE BLUE --
SHE WAS UNDERSTANDABLY FURIOUS
THAT SOMEBODY KNEW ABOUT HER
DIAGNOSIS WITHOUT HER HAVING
EVER SHARED.
SHE HAD NO IDEA HOW THE
RESEARCHER GOT HER INFORMATION
BECAUSE SHE WAS UNAWARE THAT THE
CANCER REGISTRY EXISTED.
LET ALONE THAT IT HELD HER
PERSONAL AND MEDICAL INFORMATION.
I WAS SURPRISED ALSO BECAUSE AS
A CANCER SURVIVOR MYSELF I WAS
ALSO AWARE OF THE REGISTRIES
EXISTENCE.
AND THE INFORMATION THEY CONTAIN
SURE ENOUGH I WROTE TO THE
REGISTRY AND FOUND OUT THAT THEY
HAD ALL OF MY PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
THINGS THAT.
I SPEND TIME PROTECTING AND YOU
ALSO SPEND TIME PROTECTING SUCH
AS MY SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
CURRENT REGULATIONS REQUIRE
PHYSICIANS TO MAKE PATIENTS
AWARE THAT THEIR INFORMATION IS
REQUIRED BY LAW TO BE REPORTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
I AM NOT DENYING THAT PHYSICIANS
DO THIS BUT HOW MUCH DO THEY
REALLY HOW MUCH IS A PATIENT
REALLY HERE -- WHEN YOU ARE TOLD
YOU HAVE CANCER?
I KNOW THAT I TRUST MY DOCTOR
FULLY IN ASSUME THAT HE UPHOLDS
ALL RULES AND LAWS HE'S REQUIRED
TO AN EVEN GOES ABOVE AND BEYOND
BUT I DO NOT RECALL.
EVER HEARING ANYTHING ABOUT MY
INFORMATION BEING SHARED WITH
THE STATE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH FOR THE CANCER REGISTRY.
UNDER CURRENT PRACTICE A PATIENT
RECEIVES INFORMATIONAL BROCHURE --
WHEN A RESEARCHER MAKES INITIAL
CONTACT WITH THEM?
I THINK I'M I'VE GOT -- COPIES
OF THE BROCHURE SO THAT WE CAN
ALL I TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
SO THE BROCHURE ALREADY EXISTS.
I BASS THE SURGEONS THEY HAVE
THEM OUT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
FINDING OUT.
AS A CANCER SURVIVOR.
AT THE CANCER REGISTRIES
EXISTENCE WHEN YOU'RE BEING
ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
RESEARCH STUDY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT IT WHEN
YOUR INFORMATION IS ENTERED.
SB FOUR FIFTY TO SOLVE THIS BY
SIMPLY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO SEND AN
INFORMATIONAL BROCHURE TO ALL
PATIENTS UPON BEING ENTERED INTO
THE REGISTRY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO -- ONE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ESTIMATES SENATOR -- JUST
RECENTLY -- I I HEARD AND BY THE
WAY JUST SECONDS THIS BILL BY
THE WAY -- TO ASK THIS QUESTION --
IN THERE IS ACTUALLY IN.
OF THE THE RIVER THE REP
REPUBLICAN ANALYSIS THIS
QUESTION OF WHETHER THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY AND MAYBE IF IT'S
DUPLICATIVE.
HOW CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT SURE
THE -- UNDER CURRENT -- PRACTICE
AND LAW AS A MATTER OF FACT.
WHEN YOU ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER -- IT IS -- REQUIRED BY
YOUR PHYSICIAN.
TO REPORT YOUR MEDICAL A
DIAGNOSIS CONDITION AND ALL YOUR
CANCER INFORMATION TO THE CANCER
REGISTRY.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT NOTIFY
YOU ALSO THAT THIS IS HAPPENING --
SO IF IN MY PERSONAL CASE IN IN
THE CASE OF THE CONSTITUENT OF
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD AND IT'S IN
MY OWN PERSONAL POLL OF ASKING
CANCER SURVIVORS MYSELF ABOUT
THIS PRACTICE.
I HAVE YET TO HAVE ONE CANCER
SURVIVOR TELL ME.
THAT THEY REMEMBER RECEIVING THE
INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE CANCER REGISTRY.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO HEAR I'M
NOT GONNA ARGUE TODAY THAT
DOCTORS ARE NOT DOING THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M PROPOSING AT ALL I'M
DOCTORS VERY WELL COULD BE DOING
IT.
BUT THAT INFORMATION DELIVERED
AT SUCH A TUMULTUOUS TIME IN A
CANCER.
SURVIVORS LIFE THAT THEY'RE
MISSING THAT INFORMATION FOR
WHATEVER REASON -- SO.
THE REASON THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
DUPLICATE THIS IS BECAUSE IT IS.
IN ADDITION TO THE PHYSICIAN
BEING REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION IS ALSO REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
THE CANCER REGISTRY ITSELF -- TO
LET.
CANCER SURVIVORS NO WANTS THEIR
INFORMATION IS ENTERED INTO THE
SYSTEM THAT THEY ARE IN THAT
SYSTEM THE BROCHURE TALKS ABOUT
THE CANCER REGISTRY ALL THE
POSITIVE THINGS THAT IT DOES.
AND I THINK THAT'S RECEIVED AT A
MORE OPPORTUNE TIME IN A CANCER
SURVIVORS LIFE WHEN THEY'RE ABLE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THAT AND
UNDERSTAND IT AND PROCESS IT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY OKAY.
MY CONCERN IS IS THE CURRENT
CONCERN HAS BEEN RAISED ABOUT
POTENTIAL DUPLICATION AND MAYBE
ADDED COSTS WITHOUT A ADDED
VALUE SO SO YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT
NOW AT THE EXISTING LAW REQUIRES.
SHARING OF THE BROCHURE AT THAT.
HOW THE EMOTIONAL MOMENT WHEN A
CANCER SURVIVORS DISTRAUGHT?
OF WHEN THE FIRST LEARNING ABOUT
IT AND THAT'S NOT THE BEST TIME
BUT YOUR BILL IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES THAT WHEN
THAT THEIR NAME IS ADDED TO THE
REGISTRY DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH NOTIFY.
THE HAVE THAT RIGHT THAT IS
CORRECT YES.
SO WITH THE BE NOTIFIED BOTH
TIMES.
WELL I CAN'T -- I I I CAN'T
ARGUE FOR THE PRACTICE OF THE
PHYSICIANS ON WHEN THEY'RE GOING
TO PRESENT THE INFORMATION.
SO THIS BILL WOULD MAKE SURE.
THAT TH THAT THE REGISTRY IS
ACTIVE IN.
PRODUCING THE BROCHURE AND
MAILING IT OUT SO YOU KNOW.
OR AT ONE OF THE OTHER ASPECTS
OF CONFUSION ON THIS IS.
WHEN YOU'RE UNDER A DOCTOR'S
CARE FOR SURVIVOR?
OUR OUR FOR CAN'T WHEN YOU'RE
UNDER DOCTOR'S CARE FOR CANCER
WHICH DOCTORS RESPONSIBLE FOR
TELLING YOU IS IT YOUR PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN.
IS IT YOUR ONCOLOGIST IS IT YOUR
SURGEON -- SO IN IN MY CASE I
HAD FOUR DIFFERENT DOCTORS --
TREATING ME FOR MY CANCER AND
IT'S IT'S A LEGITIMATE --
CONVERSATIONS WHICH ONE OF THOSE
WAS RESPONSIBLE AND I I WOULDN'T
ASTHE CANCER SURVIVOR BILL TELL
YOU WHICH ONE SHOULD HAVE DONE
IT.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU I DON'T
THINK IT DID HAPPEN AND THIS IS
MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE -- I JUST I HAVE
COMMENTS IN THE THE FIRST ONE
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
INTENT WITH THE BILL -- BUT I I
BELIEVE IT'S UNNECESSARY UP.
AND I WON'T BE SUPPORT I WILL BE
VOTING ON THE BILL TODAY.
I HAVE A NINE RECOMMENDATION.
CURRENTLY AS YOU WELL AS YOU
NOTED PHYSICIANS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUPPLY THIS INFORMATION -- TO
PATIENTS -- THE BILL THIS BILL
THEN THE REQUIRES DPH TO SEND
THE SAME INFORMATION.
VIA MAIL LIKE OR SOME OTHER
WHERE WE'RE NOT PRESCRIBING HOW
THEY SEND CORRECT BUT THE
REQUIRED IT TO BE SENT AGAIN AND
THAT TO ME MAKES IT.
COULD HAVE AND NOT A PRUDENT USE
OF STATE RESOURCES WHY THANK YOU
IN IT ALL BRIEFLY ADDRESS OUT OF
IT IF IT'S OKAY. ONE OF THAT YOU
KNOW AS SOME OF YOU THAT HAVE
SERVED WITH ME IN THE ASSEMBLY
RECOGNIZE IT -- WE'VE YEAH THIS
IS MY FIRST RODEO WITH THIS
PARTICULAR SUBJECT MATTER.
AND IN WORKING WITH CMA -- THEY
KIND OF SHARED THOSE CONCERNS
AND SO. TO WE'VE WE'VE KIND OF
SIMPLIFIED THE BILL AS BEST WE
CAN.
IN THE CONCERNED THAT THIS
CANCER SURVIVOR IS RECEIVING
INFORMATION AND THAT WE ALL KNOW
THE CANCER SURVIVOR IS.
ACTUALLY RECEIVING INFORMATION.
IN A AND APPRECIATE THAT -- AND
LIKE I SAID I I WON'T BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL TODAY -- AND
APPRECIATE I DO APPRECIATE THE
INTENT -- AND SO ANYWAY WITH
THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HEALTH
TAKE THAT AS MY CLOTHES THINKING
OKAY AT THE STATE EVERYBODY
ELSE'S AYE VOTE.
SO -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION -- BY
MISS THE MONA SECOND BY MISTER
MAYES THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WHAT?
WHAT NOT VOTING MAYES HI MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA FLORA AYE LOW MOAN.
MOAN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RAMOS.
I MUST NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
YOUR BILL HAS A BOAT SITS OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF
THE BROTHERS OUT ON THAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I WOULD.
LEAVE OPEN THE OPTION OF HAVING
A FOR THE CONVERSATION WITH YOU
AND AND IF YOU HAVE SOME OF
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT WE CAN.
WORK OUT I LOVE TO DO IT.
THANK YOU SIR THANK MEMBERS
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THERE WAS ARE GOING TO ROOM
MISTER PORTANTINO WAS IN A MOVIE.
THAT'S THAT MR PORTANTINO'S HERE
I WILL GO AHEAD WITH THE MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OF A SECOND.
YOU CAN'T MOTION AND SECOND OF
ALL I'M SORRY [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY I'VE JUST HEARD OF I
THOUGHT WAS ANYWAY SO SO I WILL
GIVE THE MOTION THIS YEAR MAYES
A SECOND MISTER BIGELOW.
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING AFTERNOON
OF SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONCERNED COUNTER INCLUDES ITEM
NUMBER ONE ACR NINETY EIGHT BY
MISS WICKS ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
SIXTY FIVE MY SENATOR PAN.
A NUMBER SIX SB TWO OH SEVEN BY
CENTER HER TADO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB TWO FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
DODD.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB THREE SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR PAN.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB THREE EIGHTY
TWO BY SENATOR NIELSEN AND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB SEVEN ZERO SIX
BY SENATOR GALGIANI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IN THE CONSECUTIVE.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE. FOR QUE CREO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA AND THE MOON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON. ZERO WE HAVE TWELVE
VOTES FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND CENTER PORTANTINO HERO SB
SIX HUNDRED THANK YOU -- DOCTOR
WOODS AND MEMBERS -- SENATE BILL
LIKE IT'S SENATE BILL.
SIX HUNDRED WILL MAKE CLEAR
WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT STANDARD
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES.
ONE MEDICALLY WHEN A MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENT.
MAY DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY CAUSE
INFERTILITY.
ARE COVERED BENEFIT.
BECAUSE THE LAW DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY SPELL OUT EACH AND
EVERY COVERED SERVICE.
THERE'S CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS.
MANY PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY DENIED COVERAGE.
DESPITE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE DMA CHEESE
REPEATEDLY AND CONSISTENTLY
OVERTURNING HEALTH PLAN TO NILES
OF COVERAGE. FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION THESE WRONGFUL
DELAYS AND THE NILES CONTINUE.
TO REGULARLY -- KERR AND
MULTIPLE HEALTH PLANS HAVE
BLATANTLY DIFF DEFIED THE DMA
CHEESE ORDER TO PAY THESE CLAIMS.
COVERAGE WITH PROMPT APPROVALS
FOR CARE IS CRITICAL FOR ACCESS
THE RELATIVELY HIGH OUT OF
POCKET COSTS COUPLED WITH THE
SHORT WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
UNDERGOING THESE PROCEDURES.
BETWEEN DIAGNOSE SINCE AND
CONVENTION IN.
COMMENCEMENT OF TREATMENT MAKE
THEM UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
PATIENTS WITHOUT AN HEALTH PLAN
POTENTIAL LOSS OF PARENTHOOD IS
PROFOUND CAUSING DEPRESSION A
LOWER QUALITY OF LIFE AND SOME
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN EVEN A
WILLINGNESS TO OPT FOR LESS.
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT OR FAILURE
TO EVEN IT HERE TO TREATMENT TO
TRY TO MINIMIZE LOSS OF
FERTILITY.
SB SIX HUNDRED IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS CAN OBTAIN
FERTILITY PRESERVATION
IMMEDIATELY.
ENABLING THEM TO FOCUS ON THEIR
TREATMENT OF UNDER THEIR
UNDERLYING DISEASE I WOULD
SUBMIT -- THAT.
INSURANCE COMPANIES WILL
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG
RUN BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD USE THIS SERVICE --
AND THEN DENY.
GETTING TREATMENT.
GET SICKER AND COST THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES MORE IN THE
LONG RUN WHERE IF THEY SHOULD
PRESERVE THEIR FERTILITY.
GOT CURED AND THEN WENT AND
STARTED THEIR FAMILY IT WOULD BE
A MUCH MORE SMOOTH.
TRANSITION WHAT I BELIEVE LESS
OUT OF POCKET HEALTH COSTS SO
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A NUMBER OF
EXPERTS WHO ARE GONNA TALK YOU
THROUGH WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ABOUT.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN TO OKAY AND
THAT NUMBER WOULD BE TO CORRECT.
YEAH THANK YOU I HAVE FOUR BUT
YOU GUYS GO FIRST DOCTOR ROSEN
GOES FOR OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I AM INTERESTED DIRECTOR THE
FERTILITY PRESERVATION PROGRAM
AT UCSF.
I WORK WITH PATIENTS ON A DAILY
REGULAR BASIS WHO ARE FACING
TREATMENT WHICH COULD SAVE THEIR
LIVES THAT THE COST OF THE
PARTICULARLY.
OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE
SEEN THOUSANDS OF WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE DIAGNOSED WITH
THE SIGNIFICANT MEDICAL
CONDITION.
AND THE A SIGNIFICANT
REPRODUCTIVE COMPROMISE AS A
RESULT OF THEIR LIFESAVING
TREATMENT.
WE ARE AT THIS PLACE TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE INTERSECTION OF
THE ADVANCES OF MEDICINE OF
ONCOLOGY INFERTILITY.
THE TREATMENT FOR CANCER HAS
ADVANCED SO THAT IS LARGELY
SUCCESSFUL.
BUT THE SO QUALITY OF NOT
REPRODUCING AS A RESULT OF THE
TREATMENT A DEVASTATING.
THE TECHNOLOGY FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS ADVANCED SO MUCH
THAT IS NOW BEING USED ROUTINELY
FOR WOMEN WHO WANT TO DELAY
FAMILY BUILDING.
CURRENTLY THE REMAINS A
SIGNIFICANT OBSTACLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE URGENT NEEDS OF
THESE CANCER PATIENTS DUE TO THE
LACK OF CLARIFICATION OF THE
EXISTING COVERAGE OF CODE IN
CODE.
IN WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER
PATIENTS AND PHYSICIANS MUST
DECIDE IN THE COURSE OF CARE AND
ACT QUICKLY.
THE INSURANCE COVERAGE MUST BE
CLEARLY STATED EASILY ACCESSED
HOWEVER THIS IS OFTEN NOT THE
CASE.
THIS IS COMPLICATED BY THE FACT
THAT NOT ALL SERVICES ARE LISTED
IN THE EVIDENCE.
OF COVERAGE BUT INFERTILITY
OFTEN IS LISTED TYPICALLY AS A
NON COVERED SERVICE.
THE CONFUSION BETWEEN FERTILITY
PRESERVATION INFERTILITY IS
RAMPANT AND ADDS TO THE DELAYS
IF NOT IF NOT OUTRIGHT DENIALS
SIMPLY SPECIFICALLY LISTING
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS A
COVERED BENEFIT WOULD LESSEN THE
CONFUSION.
THE CONFUSION LEADS TO DELAYS
WHICH FOR MANY OF THESE WOMEN IS
EQUIPMENT TO THE NILE TO THE
NARROW WINDOW OF WHEN THEY CAN
ACCESS THE SERVICE.
IN LIGHT OF THE CANCER TREATMENT
AS A RESULT FEWER WOMEN ARE ABLE
TO CURRENTLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
USING FERTILITY PRESERVATION
TRADE.
SO WHY IS THIS ACCESO CRITICAL.
THERE IS EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT ONE THIRD OF WOMEN.
ARE ONE THIRD OF PATIENTS
POTENTIALLY HAVE THE FERTILITY
DECISIONS INFLUENCE THEIR
TREATMENT DECISIONS WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE COVERAGE FOR TO LEE
PRESERVATION FOR GOING
RECOMMENDED TREATMENT.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THE
PATIENTS WITHOUT THE OPTION
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SCORE
WORSE ON MEASURES OF QUALITY OF
LIFE AND SATISFACTION WITH LIFE.
WE ARE SEEING THAT THE LACK OF
COVERAGE COULD EVEN IMPACT THEIR
CHANCE OF SURVIVING THEIR CANCER.
IN CONCLUSION CLARIFICATION THE
EXISTING COVERAGE FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION WOULD PROVIDE A
BETTER CARE.
GIVING A PERSON BOTH THEIR LIFE.
AND THEIR DREAM OF A BIOLOGIC
FAMILY.
THANK YOU AND I BEHALF OF UCSF
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE.
MY PATIENCE AND MYSELF I ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WOULD AN HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SENATE
BILL.
SIX HUNDRED MY NAME IS JOYCE
REINECKE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE ALLIANCE
FOR FERTILITY PRESERVATION.
BUT I AM ALSO A CANCER SURVIVOR
AND I HAD TO GO THROUGH
FERTILITY PRESERVATION TO HAVE
MY OWN CHILDREN.
THROUGH MY WORK OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE MET HUNDREDS
OF CANCER PATIENTS SURVIVORS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS AND I'VE HEARD
THEIR FEARS ABOUT THEIR CANCER.
BUT ALSO ABOUT THEIR CHANCE OF
HAVING CHILDREN.
YEARS AGO OPTIONS FOR THESE
PATIENTS WERE LIMITED.
AND THERE REALLY WASN'T A
DISCUSSION ABOUT INSURANCE
COVERAGE.
BUT AS YOU'VE JUST HEARD THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS ADVANCED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND IS NOW
CONSIDERED STANDARD BY ALL OF
THE RELEVANT -- CANCER AND
REPRODUCTIVE SOCIETIES.
INSURERS BY AND LARGE HOWEVER
HAVE NOT UPDATED THEIR COVERAGES
TO REFLECT THIS REALITY.
THEY HAVE AVOIDED COVERING
FERTILITY PRESERVATION BY
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT IT AS A
TYPE OF INFERTILITY TREATMENT.
AND THEREFORE ELECTIVE AN
EXCLUDED.
BUT I WOULD PUT TO YOU THAT THE
LOSS OF FERTILITY IS NOT MERELY
A MEDICAL COMPLICATION.
THIS AFFECTS REPRODUCTION AND
EFFECTS PARENTHOOD WHICH ARE
FUNDAMENTAL LIFE FUNCTIONS.
AND THAT DESERVE THE HIGHEST
ORDER PROTECTION.
BUT AT A MINIMUM WE ASK THAT AT
LEAST THESE SERVICES BE TREATED
THE SAME WAY AS OTHER MEDICAL
SIDE EFFECTS THAT ARE
ENCOUNTERED IN CANCER TREATMENT.
SUCH AS ANTI NAUSEA MEDICATIONS
PROSTHETICS AND BREAST
RECONSTRUCTION THESE ARE SEEN AS
INTEGRAL TO CANCER CARE AND AS A
RESULT THEY ARE COVERED.
THANKFULLY STATES AND BODIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
INCREASINGLY ADOPTED THIS VIEW.
AND IN THE LAST TWO YEARS SIX
STATES AND THE VETERANS HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ENACTED THIS
COVERAGE.
AND THERE ADDITIONAL BILLS THAT
ARE PENDING RIGHT NOW.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
HAS ALREADY RECOGNIZED INSURERS
LEGAL OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE THIS
COVERAGE FOR THESE PATIENTS.
THIS BUTTE CAME ABOUT AFTER A
DELIBERATE EFFORT THAT WE WERE
INVOLVED IN TO HELP CANCER
PATIENTS CHALLENGE DENIALS OF
COVERAGE.
THE INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEWS
IN ALL OF THESE CASES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT IN THE
FACE OF POTENTIALLY STERILIZING
CANCER TREATMENT.
FERTILITY PRESERVATION WAS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN COVERED.
THEY HAVE UNIFORMLY OVERTURN THE
INSURERS TO NILES.
THESE HAVE BEEN GREAT OUTCOMES
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL PATIENTS WHO
WERE INVOLVED BUT THIS IS NOT A
VIABLE PATH FOR COVERAGE FOR THE
MAJORITY OF PATIENTS.
THEY'RE IN THE MIDST OF A LIFE
ALTERING MEDICAL CRISIS A
DIAGNOSIS OF CANCER.
AND THEY CANNOT REASONABLY BE
EXPECTED TO UNDERTAKE A TIME
CONSUMING FINANCIALLY RISKY
APPEAL PROCESS.
ESPECIALLY FOR COVERAGE THAT THE
T. MHC HAS RECOGNIZED THEY
ALREADY HAVE.
THESE KINDS OF DELAYS WHETHER
THEY'RE DELIBERATE OR WHETHER
THEY ARE INADVERTENT HAVE THE
SAME AFFECT ON THE PATIENT.
THE DISPUTES BECOME TO NILES
ONCE SOMEONE IS LEFT IN BERLIN
STARTED TREATMENT.
NO FAVORABLE I AM MARK IN
REVERSE THIS DAMAGE SO THE
CLARITY OF COVERAGE IS ESSENTIAL.
FOR THIS REASON I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU PASS THIS MEASURE
THANK.
THEY'RE HERE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN IS TO
SHIP NINE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALTAMONTE IN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SO MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF SUSAN
G. KOMEN ALSO IN SUPPORT.
IT'S OR ANYONE ELSE OUT IS ABOUT
A CO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE WITH
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE OPPOSITION.
QUESTION SIDE OVER.
ONE THE OPPOSITION HAS REPLACED
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF ETHNIC LOUISE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
OR CAP CAP IS TAKING AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON SB --
SIX HUNDRED WHICH IS A NEW
MANDATE THAT RETRO ACTIVELY
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO COVER
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM -- FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS.
THE MANDATE EXCEEDS THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
PACKAGE AS ESTABLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN.
TWENTY TWELVE IN ITS CURRENT
FORM.
SB SIX HUNDRED CONTAINS
UNPRECEDENTED RETROACTIVITY
LANGUAGE STATING THE LEGISLATION
IS DECLARATORY OF EXISTING LAW.
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS NOT A
COVERED BENEFIT UNDER EXISTING
LAW.
THE RETROACTIVITY LANGUAGE IN
OUR VIEW CREATES A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
SUCH RETROACTIVITY CREATES
UNACCEPTABLE IN A NOBLE
UNKNOWABLE LIABILITY FOR PLANS
WHICH FOR YEARS EXCLUDED THIS
COVERAGE WITH THE PERMISSION IN
THE APPROVAL OF STATE REGULATORS.
THE RISK IN A LIABILITY FOR
HEALTH PLANS AND BY EXTENSION
THEIR ENROLLEES FROM IMPOSING
RETROACTIVITY ARE UNKNOWN BUT
LIKELY SUBSTANTIAL.
THIS PROVISION OF THE BILL MUST
BE REMOVED.
THERE IS A LONG STANDING HISTORY
ON FERTILITY PRESERVATION --
WHICH IS EVIDENCED BY SEVENTEEN
YEARS OF ACTION TAKEN BY STATE
REGULATORS -- THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH -- THESE -- ACTIONS
INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING.
THE LEGISLATURE INTHE
ADMINISTRATION ADOPTING AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
PACKAGE THROUGH THE SELECTION OF
A BENCHMARK PLAN THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION SERVICES.
PRIOR BILLS ATTEMPTING TO ADD
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES
AS A COVERED BENEFIT FAILED TO
PASS IN TWO OCCASIONS.
AND A STRONG VETO MESSAGE BY
GOVERNOR BROWN ON A THIRD BILL.
EIGHTY NINE TWELVE CLEARLY
STATED THAT FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS NOT AN ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFIT QUOTE.
WELL I UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE TO
PRESERVE FERTILITY WHERE
POSSIBLE SUCH COVERAGE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED JUST LAST YEAR. FOR
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
COVERAGE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE OF FOR YEARS APPROVED
HEALTH PLAN EVIDENCE OF COVERAGE
DOCUMENT SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDING
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS A
COVERED BENEFIT.
THE ALSO APPROVED COVERAGE
WRITERS FOR THIS SERVICE.
FURTHER UNDERLYING THAT
FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS NOT
REQUIRED SERVICE BUT AN OPTIONAL.
ONE NEITHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES NOR CITY I
HAVE ISSUED ANY REGULATIONS NOR
DO THEY HAVE THAT AUTHORITY IN
OUR VIEW -- THE INDEPENDENT
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE WAS A
DISCREPANCY REGARDING FERTILITY
PRESERVATION AS A COVERED
BENEFIT.
THE TEAMMATE SEE BELIEVES IT IS
A BENEFIT.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE DID NOT FURTHERMORE WE
RECEIVE COMMUNICATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CLARIFYING THAT THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM DOES NOT
CURRENTLY COVER THE SERVICE.
THE ISSUE HERE IS NOT THE
SERVICE ITSELF BUT RATHER THE
UNPRECEDENTED PROCESS BY WHICH
THE MANDATE IS BEING PLACED IN
THE LAW RETROACTIVELY.
RETROACTIVELY ESTABLISHING
BENEFITS DIMINISH HIS OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN
ESTABLISHING BENEFITS WHICH IS
THE POWER IMPROPERLY REVIEWING
THEIR COST.
HOWEVER IN THIS CASE IF THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS TO
PROSPECTIVELY ESTABLISH
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES
THAT'S A COVERED BENEFIT.
OUTSIDE OF THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS PROCESS THE BILL MUST
BE NARROWED IN CLARIFIED TO A
PUT SOME PARAMETERS AROUND THIS
NEW COVERAGE BENEFITS.
IF THE RETROACTIVITY LANGUAGES
REMOVED WE ARE WILLING TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS TO DISCUSS THE
PARAMETERS AROUND THIS COVERAGE
PROSPECTIVELY -- I WOULD JUST
FROM AND WE SUPPLIED AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION I WOULD
JUST YOU KNOW I WOULD JUST
FINALLY SAY MEMBERS -- COVER
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT --
PREMIUMS IN TWENTY TWENTY YOU'RE
GOING UP BY LESS THAN 1% IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET.
THIS IS REMARKABLE PROGRESS AND
THAT'S A RESULT OF A CONSCIOUS
MARTIN TOUGH POLICY DECISIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MADE
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
STABILIZE THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET.
PASSING NEW AND EXPENSIVE
BENEFIT MANDATES PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT -- HAVE A OF A FALSE
DECLARATORY EXISTING LAW
COMPONENTS -- THREATEN TO WIPE%
OUT THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
THEREFORE WE OPPOSE THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU.
ANYONE CAN TELL ME HAVE OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIKE
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE TO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED -- POSITION WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RETROACTIVE PIECE THEY WON'T
BELABOR MANY OF THE ISSUES WE
ARE OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO THOSE
PATIENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
AND PROVIDERS WHO ARE ATTEMPTING
TO PROVIDE SERVICES BUT WE DO
THINK THAT IS THE LEGISLATORS.
RIGHT RESPONSIBILITY TO PASS --
MANDATES GOING FORWARD ON A
PROSPECTIVE BASIS AND THE
CONCEPT OF PUTTING IN PLACE A
RETROACTIVE NATURE ESPECIALLY TO
THE DEGREE.
THAT IT IGNORES THE FACT THAT
THE INSURANCE -- COMMISSIONER IS
INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED AND HAS A
DIFFERENT ROBUST BODY OF LAW
THAT COVERS THE PRODUCTS UNDER
CDI WHICH IS A DIFFERENT --
VIEWPOINT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS A COVERED BENEFIT.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR IF THERE IS AN ABILITY --
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD AND
POTENTIALLY AMEND THE BILL TO
TAKE OUT THE RIGHT TRACK TO
PEACE.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO.
JOHN WE GOT WE HAVE AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ALSO POSE
LIST AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
KAREN CIRCUIT SCENE WITH CAL
CHAMBER WHERE POST AS WELL THANK
YOU.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THIS TO ME.
SENATOR THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
FOR TO KNOW THAT -- YOU FOR DONE
SOME WORK ALSO LOOKING NOTICING
THAT YOU'RE QUITE A BIT SUPPORT
OVER -- OVER IN THE SENATE --
BUT IT SEEMED LIKE THAT -- THE
QUESTION ABOUT THIS SORT OF
RETRO ACTIVE VERSUS PERSPECTIVE --
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING I
WOULD SUPPORT ON A PROSPECTIVE
BASIS BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT --
THIS IDEA OF OF THAT LANGUAGE
ABOUT -- DEVELOPING RETROACTIVE
IN THE MAYBE EVEN SOME -- LEGAL
LIABILITY THAT MIGHT THAT BE
DRAWN FROM NEXT SO CAN YOU DRESS
THEM.
YEAH THE SECOND PART I THINK IS
THE EASIEST PART I DON'T THINK
THERE'S LEGAL LIABILITY -- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR ANALYSIS OUR POINT
IS PRECISELY BECAUSE THAT PEACE
IS BEING.
DISCUSSED IS WHY WE NEED TO MAKE
IT CLEAR OF WHAT THE CURRENT LAW --
IS SAYING AND WHY WERE RE
STATING THAT CURRENT LAW.
THE OTHER PIECE WHICH IS NOT FOR
YOUR QUESTION BUT I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE I BROUGHT ALL
THE HEALTH PLANS INTO MY OFFICE
AND I SAID I DON'T WANT TO DO A
BILL.
JUST SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND I SAID TAKE A YEAR.
YOU KNOW TO FIND YOUR BENEFIT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS WHEN THE
ORIGINAL MANDATES WERE CREATED.
THE ADVANCES IN FERTILITY
PRESERVATION DIDN'T EXIST AND I
SAID NOW THAT THEY'RE THERE GO
AHEAD AND DO IT.
SO IT WAS WITH RELUCTANCE THAT I
WENT INTO THIS BUT NOW THAT IT'S
BEEN A DECADE LATER.
EACH STEP OF THE WAY WE REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN GETTING THE SUPPORT
THAT I THOUGHT.
PEOPLE WOULD EMBRACE GIVEN THE
ADVANCES OF OF TECHNOLOGY AND
WHERE FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS
TODAY THE OTHER PART OF THE
RETROACTIVITY THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
AFFECTED.
WOULD BE A VERY VERY SMALL
AMOUNT WE KNOW THAT NUMBER
WHAT'S THAT THE NUMBER YOU GUYS
WANT.
TO WHO WANTS TO JUMP IN ON SORRY
I'VE YOU MEAN THE NUMBER PER
YEAR THAT WOULD BE DIAGNOSED IN
NO NO THOSE THING BECAUSE BY NOW
IT WOULD BE IF IT'S RETROACTIVE
THOSE THAT WOULD WOULD HAVE
WOULD BE USING THIS -- THAT WAS
RETRACTED FROM THEIR DIAGNOSIS
NOT RETROACTIVE FROM A CALENDAR
PROJECT RIGHT RIGHT -- BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE WERE PART
OF LAST WEEK WITH THE D. MHC I
KNOW THAT THEY SAID THAT THERE
ARE EXISTING ROLES WITHIN THE
PLANS ABOUT -- YOU KNOW KIND OF
STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS AS TO
WHEN SOMEONECAN BRING A CLAIM
AND THAT'S ALREADY YOU'RE NOT
CHANGING THOSE PIECES WE'RE JUST
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO.
ARE WARRANTED COVERAGE GET IT IF
IT WAS MESSED WITHIN.
THAT TIME FRAME NOT GOING BACK
FIVE YEARS AND SAYING YOU WERE
SHOULD HAVE HAD THIS THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS TIME IT'S WITHIN
THE TIME FRAME OF THEIR
DIAGNOSIS.
MAKING SURE THAT IT IT'S COVERED
AND CLARIFYING THE LAW TO DO
THAT.
SO IT MIGHT HAVE WITH THE FACT
THAT THE OPPOSITION CAN ONE AND
TALK ABOUT THAT IN REGARDS TO
THE SHE WANTS TO JUMP IN IF I'M
SURE THAT GARY -- FROM OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE YOU KNOW
STATING THAT SOMETHING IS
RETROACTIVE IS SIMPLY.
AN ACCURATE CHARACTERIZATION.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO STATE THAT
IT'S SIMPLY DECLARATORY EXISTING
LAW THEREFORE THERE CAN BE NO
RETROACTIVITY LEGALLY SPEAKING
AND MY CALL YOUR CAN SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE BUT BUT BUT IF I
CAN IF IT'S DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW THEN WHAT WHAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF OF OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DENYING THAT WE
COVERAGE UNDER EXISTING LAW
THERE'S FORCING THESE APPEALS
AND EVERY APPEAL HAS BEEN
OVERTURNED.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
THEY'RE SAYING IN THEIR
ARGUMENTS THAT THE LAW IS IN
CLEAR.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE LAW IS CLEAR EVERYONE
OF THE APPEALS HAS BEEN
OVERTURNED BUT WHAT I THINK I
HEARD IS THEY'RE SAYING THAT THE
EXISTING LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE --
THIS AND SO IF IT YEAH GOD SO IF
I MAY UM THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE ISSUED A
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER A FEW
MONTHS AGO -- AND TO THE
SPECIFICALLY STATED ALL OF THE
ABOVE FERTILITY PRESERVATION
SERVICES REQUIRE CONSULTATIONS
OUTPATIENT SURGICAL PROCEDURES
AND PREVENTATIVE HEALTHCARE.
SERVICES ALL OF WHICH ARE
DEFINED AS A BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICE UNDER THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE MORE OVER IF
WE LOOK AT THE TO BURKE ANALYSIS --
YOU KNOW SPEAKING TO THE FACT
THAT IT EXCEEDS THE ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS CLEAN.
STATES SB SIX HUNDRED IS
UNLIKELY TO EXCEED THE ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS DIEM ACTUALLY
CONFIRMED TO TO BURKE THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
FERTILITY PRESERVATION TO
ADDRESS POTENTIAL IOTA JANET
INFERTILITY EASY BASIC HEALTH
CARE SERVICE WITHIN THE MEANING
OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
SECTION. THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE ONE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY FOR THE AND
REALLY ISN'T IN OPPOSITION TO
DRESS THAT.
YET SO -- WELL SEVERAL THINGS
WERE -- INCLUDED AS A PART THAT
WE WE WHICH SPECIFIC COMPONENT
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO ADDRESS
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU THAT'S THE
DESPITE THIS BUT I MEAN.
WHAT WHAT SHE HAD JUST REFERRED
TO HAVE THIS IDEA FOR IF IT WERE
SAYING THAT IT'S THAT IF IT IS
THE EXISTING LAW?
YEAH NO THE EGGS EXISTING LAW
DOES NOT REQUIRE FERTILITY
PRESERVATION TO BE COVERED -- I
WE THINK IT'S WE THINK IT'S
PRETTY QUICK CLEAR -- THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION PICKED AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
PACKAGE THEY PICKED.
AN EXISTING PRODUCT THATWAS ON
THE MARKET TO SERVE AS THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THAT
PRODUCT DID NOT -- INCLUDE
COVERAGE.
FOR FERTILITY PRESERVATION AND
THIS CONCEPT THAT THIS IS A
BASIC HEALTH CARE SERVICE -- WE
THINK -- IS A FAULTY ARGUMENT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
EXCLUSIVE AUTHORITY TO DEFINE.
THE BENEFITS AND THE SERVICES
THAT ARE TO BE COVERED BY HEALTH
PLANS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT LACKS
THE POWER TO UNILATERALLY EXPAND
THOSE BENEFITS AND SERVICES --
THE DECISION TO WHAT CONSTITUTES
A A A SERVICE IS A POLICY
DECISION THAT IN OUR VIEW IS
SOLELY IN THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO
AND SO I'M I'M HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE TWO WONDERING IF.
IF THE LEADS SO IN REGARDS TO TO
SAYING THAT THAT THE LAW ALREADY
EXISTED THIS SHOULD BE A COVERED
BENEFIT.
THE DA POSITION IS SAYING NO THE
BILL SAYING YES IT IS -- SO IS
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE PROPER
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION OR THE COURTS THE
PROPER PLACE TO BE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION BECAUSE IF IN
THE PAST YOU GUYS OF SAID NO
IT'S NOT A COVERED BENEFIT
THERE'S A NO ACTUALLY IS A
COVERED.
BENEFIT THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
CRUX OF THE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT SO IF WE WE'VE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS WE ARE WILLING TO
ENTER INTO A DISCUSSION WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR. TO WORK
ON THIS BILL IF THE
RETROACTIVITYPEACE IS REMOVED
SO THAT WE CAN PROSPECTIVELY
ESTABLISH COVERAGE FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION SERVICES SO IF I
CAN JUST FOR SECOND THINKING
NOUN SO THAT STATE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOUR YEARS
AGO WHEN DID YOU CITIES FIRST
ARE WORKING ON THE 600-010-22000
AND TEN IN CENTER PORTANTINO BUT
THE TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PORTANTINO -- I BELIEVE THAT
THIS WAS -- SOMETHING THAT WAS
COVERED AND THAT -- AND SO.
AT WHAT POINT DO WE DECIDED THIS
IS A COVERED BENEFIT ONE IT
SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
THIS WAS A COVER BENEFIT NOT NOW
WE'RE SAYING IT'S NOT.
THERE'S GOT A BILL TO SAY NO IT
WAS A COVERED BENEFIT HAS BEEN A
COVER BENEFIT ALL ALONG -- OKAY
SO.
WHAT WHY NOT SAY SO SO WHY NOT
SAID TODAY THAT IT IS AND --
WHAT WE?
SO WHAT WHAT WHERE YOU OPPOSED
TO THE THE IF THE IF THE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T DECIDE IS A
COVERED BENEFIT ANIMAL SUPPORT
AMONGST THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
HOUSE -- BUT TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT IT IS A COVERED BENEFIT ONE
WITH THAT DATE START WHEN WOULD
YOU BE COMFORTABLE THAT DATE
STARTING.
RIGHT SO AT THE YOU KNOW WHEN SO
WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN THAT ARE
AMENDMENTS.
AND I'LL HAVE TO BREAK THOSE OUT.
IN ORDER TO GET THE EXACT DATE
BUT TYPICALLY IT WOULD BE --
UPON RENEWAL THE NEXT POLICY OR
OR THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO DID
THE START DATE WOULD BE -- YOU
KNOW THE FIRST OF THE YEAR WHO'D
BE YOU KNOW ONCE POLICIES ARE
RENEWED UPON AFTER THAT UPON
AFTER THAT.
IF I MAY THROUGH THE CHAIR.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO TELL ON THE
HEAD I MEAN WE'RE HERE BECAUSE
WE'RE SQUABBLING ABOUT EXISTING
LAW.
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED THIS BILL
AND THE POINT THAT THE A
LEGISLATURE'S APPROPRIATE PLACE
TO DRAW THE LINE.
I'M ASKING.
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
HELP ME DRAW THE LINE AS THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO HELP TO
DRAW THAT LINE IT WE JUST DON'T
WANT TO GO BACK IN TIME BECAUSE
IT OPENS OUR FIRST OF ALL IT'S
WRONG ON THE LAW.
IN NUMBER TWO WOULD EXPOSE OUR
PLAN.
TO PLANS.
TO UNKNOWN IN UNTOLD LIABILITIES
FOR THOSE WHO FEEL LIKE IT WAS
EXISTING LAW AND NOW WE HAVE A
LAW DECLARING THAT ITS EXISTING
LAW WHEN IT'S NOT -- AND SO
THAT'S AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THE LANGUAGE SAYS IT SAYS THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CONSTITUTE A
CHANGE ALONG.
THEN WHY HAVE THE BILL.
BUT BUT IF IT ISN'T AS IF IT IS
AN EXISTING LAW.
THEN YOU COULD GO TO THE COURT
INSTANT THE COURT COULD SAY NO
IT WASN'T EXISTING LAW.
RIGHT.
SURE THAT'S THAT'S A POSSIBILITY
SO JUST BY SAYING TODAY THAT ITS
EXISTING LOT WITH THAT WELL WHY
WOULD I MEAN WE WE WE WANT TO
TRY WILL [inaudible]
YEAH.
IF I MAYES.
YEAH ONE VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS BY
THE WAY IT'S HARD NOT YOU'RE
DOING YEAH.
USING ONE VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT
OF THAT DECLARATION THAT IT IS
EXISTING LAW IS MEANT TO ADDRESS
THESE -- BAIT AND STATUTORY
TIMELINES WHERE BY -- ENROLLEES
HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME TO
FILE A GRIEVANCE WITH THEIR
HEALTH PLAN AND THEY HAVE SIX
MONTHS TO FILE FOR AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW WITH
THE DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE.
SO BY DECLARING THAT THIS IS
EXISTING LAW -- WERE SAYING THAT
THOSE TIME LINES HAVE ALREADY
RUN BECAUSE THEY YOU KNOW PRE
DATED THIS NEW THAT SEES ME THIS
BILL -- SO IMAGINE THEN WITH OUT
THIS APPEARS IF YOU DON'T SAY
THAT THIS IS EXISTING LAW AND
THE IMPLICATION IS THAT YOU WERE
CHANGING THE LAW WHEREBY YOU
RESTART THESE TIME LINES AND YOU
OPEN THE GATES TO SAY WELL.
NOW YOU HAVE SIX MONTHS TO
SUBMIT AN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW OR YOU HAVE -- HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS THIS MAN GROUP
MISTER HEALTH PLAN.
I'M STILL CONFUSED MISTER CHAIR
MAYBE SOMEBODY ELSE CAN HELP ME
OUT [inaudible]
MISS BURKE.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT I AM SO SORRY I
JUST SOMEONE ELSE.
I I I I JUST RAMOS AND GO AHEAD
OF I MEAN TO BE SUPER QUICK I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT WHAT EXISTING LAWS BUT THE
COURTS HAS UP HOLDING YOUR
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT THE LAW
IS. NINE I I'M ASKING SENATOR NO
IT HASN'T GONE IT HAS TO BE AN
EDUCATED IN THE COURTS SO WHY DO
YOU ENVISION AS WE USED TO DO.
IT OKAY IS A CEASE AND DESIST
ORDER ISSUED BY THE DEMON SHE TO
A SPECIFIC HEALTH.
HM AC SAYS THAT YES YOUR
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW IT'S
CORRECT RIGHT THERE
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW THAT
WERE ADELINE IT'S THEIR
INTERPRETATION A LOT OKAY.
SO NOW MY QUESTION IS BECAUSE WE
TALKED ABOUT CLEAN SO IT'S FROM
THE TIME SO I'M TRYING TO GO
BACK TO THE RETROACTIVITY SO.
FROM THE TIME THERE'S A
DIAGNOSIS HOW LONG DOES SOMEONE
HAVE TO DO THEIR PRESERVATION.
OUT OF THE IT IN GENERAL IT
DEPENDS IT'S A GOOD QUESTION BUT
I WOULD SAY ROUGHLY THEY HAVE
ABOUT.
MEN LET'S SAY LESS THAN A WEEK
WOULD BE VERY CONSERVATIVE -- TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THE DECISION.
BECAUSE THE CANCER TREATMENT IS.
OF THE IMMEDIATE NATURE.
SO IN THAT TREATMENT IN GENERAL
TAKES A COUPLE WEEKS SO THE
SOONER THEY START.
THEN THE LAST DELAYS THERE ARE
IN THEIR TREATMENT.
BECAUSE THE DELAYS COULD
POTENTIALLY CAUSE OTHER PETS FOR
COMPROMISE RIGHT SO IT'S AN
IMMEDIATE DECISION RIGHT AND SO
WHEN YOU WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
RETROACTIVITY THE THE INSURANCE
PLANS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
SUED BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVEN'T HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT I WANT
TO UNDERSTAND.
THE THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS --
AND AND AND THAT'S ACOSTA CAN'T
BE QUANTIFIED.
PLANS DID NOT BUILD THIS INTO
THEIR RATES.
SO -- BECAUSE IT'S NOT A COVERED
SERVICE AND NOT ONLY IS IT NOT A
COVERED SERVICE -- IT WAS -- IT
WAS IT WAS APPROVED AS AN ON
COVERED SERVICE BY THE REGULATOR
SO WE WILL.
WE ARE TOLD WAS OKAY NOT TO
COVER.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THAT THE AND
EVERY APPEAL HAS BEEN GRANTED
RIGHT SO THE I MEAN AND NOT SO
SO EVERY SO EVERY DECISION IS
KIND OF CODIFIED THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY IS.
IN THEIR INTERPRETATION YEAH
KEEPING YOUR EYES IN YOUR THEIR
INTERPRETATION THAT THIS IS WHAT
THE LAW MEANT -- AND SO WHAT AT
WHAT LEVEL LIKE SENATOR DO YOU
THINK WHEN THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
AT A LAWSUIT WHAT LEVELS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT AND FOR HOW LONG
IS THIS ALL THE WAY BACK FROM
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN YOUR
ESTIMATION THAT THEY WOULD.
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT.
TO NO BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE
TYPE OF RETROACTIVITY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THE RETROACTIVITY OF SERVICE
WE'RE NOT OPENING UP THE
RETROACTIVITY FOR LIABILITY OKAY
SO THAT THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE
KEY TO AND THAT WE THINK THE
LIABILITY ISSUE REALLY JUST A
RED HERRING. TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT MAKE LEGISLATORS
CONCERNED I AM THAT'S MY
INTERPRETATION GOT IT THANK YOU.
RAMOS THANK YOU IN -- CENTER
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD -- MY QUESTIONS
ALSO -- ARE CENTERED AROUND THE
RETRO ACTIVITY AND TRYING TO GET
A A TIME FRAME FROM READING THE
BILL THERE'S DIFFERENT DATES
THAT ARE IN THERE. ONE IS
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SO ARE WE TALKING
RETRO ACTIVE TO THAT DATE AS FAR
AS EXISTING LAWN THIS BILL WOULD
STATE THAT THESE PROVISIONS ARE
DEFINITE TORY OF THE EXISTING
LAW.
TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
THEN WE HAVE THE OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL.
ON PAGE FIVE SECTION FOR THE
COULD BE -- CONSTRUED AS GOING
AS FAR BACK AS AS TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE SOME LOOKING FOR SOME
CLARITY.
ON THAT -- IT IF THERE HAS BEEN
ONGOING DISCUSSION ON THAT ARE
PERHAPS IF THERE IS GOING TO BE
ON GOING DISCUSSION ON THESE
COMPONENTS.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
ONGOING DISCUSSION I MEAN IN OUR
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE MHC WANTS
WITH THE APPEALS PROCESS WITH.
THE THE CARE GRABBERS OF HOW TO
APPROACH THIS TO PROVIDE THE
CARE WE THINK THIS CLARITY OF
LANGUAGE.
DOES ALL OF THOSE THINGS I MEAN
I'M I'M I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT.
IF THAT.
RETROACTIVITY PIECE AYE AYE.
FRANKLY I THINK IT'S A RED
HERRING BUT I'M I'M OPEN TO
SITTING DOWN WITH FOLKS TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT AND BRING THE
EMAIL THE MHC IN THE ROOM.
I I I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THE MHC -- THIS IS THE
ROUTE DIRECTION THAT THE CLARITY
IS IS WARRANTED BUT I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
SO ARE THE DATES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- TO THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE OTHER SECTION
AS FAR AS THE RETROACTIVITY --
ON PAGE WHAT PAGE AND FOR WHAT
PATRON SO ON PAGE -- ONE DEALS
WITH -- JANUARY FIRST. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO INCLUDE AT
A MINIMUM COVERAGE OF ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS INCLUDING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AS THE FINE.
THEN THE NEXT SECTION THIS BILL
WOULD CLARIFY.
RIGHT THAT INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP
HEALTH CARE SIR THAT'S THE
EXISTING LAW SO THIS IDEA ALONG
WITH THAT RETROACTIVITY FROM
EXISTING LAW ONCE IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD BUT THAT THE YOU
DIGEST YOUR READING IS THE
EXISTING LAW WE'RE NOT.
CHANGING IT SAYS UNDER IN THAT
NEXT SESSION THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY AND THEN THAT'S OR TALK
ABOUT NOW RIGHT WOULD MAKE THE
EXISTING LAW THAT THEN WOULD
CLARIFY WHAT THE LAW WAS IN
JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO WE
TALKING ABOUT GOING BACK TO THAT
DATE OR ARE WE STILL TALKING
ABOUT.
GOING AS FAR BACK AS TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE I THINK
QUIRK CLARIFYING IT FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT'S SO ANY
ANY TALK OF RETROACTIVITY WOULD
ONLY GO BACK AT THIS POINT. TO
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I BELIEVE
THAT IS CORRECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING THESE
ISSUES UP AND I THINK IT DOES --
AT LEAST FOR ME -- FURTHER
DISCUSSION MAYBE WE CAN MEET
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND AND OTHERS
TO TRY TO CLARIFY THAT COMPONENT
ABSENT FROM YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT WERE
CENTERED AROUND AS FAR AS A
RETRO.
ACTIVELY GOING BACK.
TO IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WERE.
AGREED.
TO THAT THAT'S THE RIGHT
PERCEPTION OF THAT [inaudible]
SENATOR.
STRUGGLING MADDOX PLAYING THIS.
THE STANDARD OF CARE BECAME
EFFECTIVEIN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RIGHT THAT'S
WHEN THE STANDARD OF CARE WAS
CREATED.
WE'RE NOT GOING BACK IN TIME AND
SAYING.
THAT WE'RE JUST SAYING THAT THE
TIMELINE THAT WAS IN EXISTING
LAW IS THE TIMELINE.
THE RETROACTIVITY PART IS ON THE
TREATMENT PART.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF SOMEBODY TODAY.
WAS DIAGNOSED AND THIS LAW WERE
TO COME INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY.
THAT PERSON WHO STILL ELIGIBLE
WHO HASN'T BECOME INFERTILE.
HAS THIS RETROACTIVE.
ABILITY TO GET.
FERTILITY PRESERVATION.
SO IF SOMEBODY WAS TEN YEARS AGO.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THEY'RE
LIABLE FOR NOT GETTING IT BUT IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY IN THIS WINDOW
BEFORE THE LAW BECOMES.
EFFECTIVE.
THEY'D BE ENTITLED TO THAT
TREATMENT.
WHAT IS IT THAT THE THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE RETROACTIVITY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND THAT'S THE
QUESTION OF WHAT WHAT TIME ARE
WE FOLLOWING BUT THE MEDICAL?
TREATMENT DEFINES THAT I MEAN IF
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS IS WHY
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY IF
SOMEBODY HAD CHEMO LAST YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE NOW.
MOST LIKELY INFERTILE.
SO THEY COULDN'T GET.
THE FERTILITY PRESERVATION.
BUT IF SOMEBODY WERE TO BE
DIAGNOSED TOMORROW.
AND FOR DIDN'T WANT TO GET
TREATED UNTIL JANUARY WHEN THIS
BECOMES LAW.
THEY WOULD BE ENTITLED FOR THAT.
TAKE A STATE BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT INFERTILE RIGHT NOW.
IT WHEN WE LOOK FORWARD TO TO
DISCUSS ANY OF THEM IS THAT
RIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD MAKE IT
CLEAR HAVE IT ALL OF THAT'S MY
CLOTHES THANK.
WE'RE NOT DONE I KNOW WE HAVE.
YEAH [inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
AND NOT JUST CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION OF RETROACTIVITY
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE A BIG
ISSUE THE ROUND UP ON IF THIS
BILL GOES OUT OUR HOPE -- CENTER
YOU CAN CONTINUE WORKING
OPPOSITION -- CLARIFY THAT AND
MAKE IT BETTER WHERE WE CAN MORE
UNDERSTAND AND WORK WITH THAT SO
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN WORK THEM ON
IT FOR BILL GETS OUT THANKS
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU I THINK I WOULD LOVE
TO KNOW YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ON ON SOME OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN THE LAST YEAR.
YEAH I MEAN SO I ITEMS TO READ
FROM THE BILL BECAUSE I THINK --
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR -- VIEW DITION
OF THIS SECTION -- TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE ME INSURANCE
CODE DOES NOT CONSTITUTE A
CHANGING BUT IS DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW THERE NO PARAMETERS
AROUND.
I'M IN EVEN IF THEY WERE WE
WOULD STILL OPPOSE THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT BENEFIT MANDATES
CAN BE MADE RETROACTIVE.
BECAUSE THE STANDARD OF CARE
THAT WAS REFERENCED EARLIER IS
THE STANDARD OF CARE CHANGE THAT
WAS MADE UNILATERALLY BY THE
STATE REGULATOR IN THE STATE
REGULATOR CAN NOT RIGHT THE LAW.
WE THE PLAN THAT WAS THE SUBJECT
OF THAT SEASON DESIST ORDERS
CHALLENGING THAT CEASE DESIST
ORDER.
AND YOU KNOW -- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS HAS
ACTUALLY FILED A WRIT OF
PETITIONS SUPERIOR COURTS -- TO
ORDER THE DO YOU NEED TO SEE
FROM EXERCISING ITS POWERS UNDER
THE KNOX KEEN ACT.
OF FROM EXCEEDING I SHOULD SAY
SORRY EXCEEDING ITS POWERS UNDER
THE KNOX KEEN ACT -- THE RATE IS
NOT A A REFLECTION OF THE
SERVICE ITSELF AS YOU KNOW I'VE
SAID WE'RE WILLING TO WORK ON
THIS -- BUT YOU KNOW IT'S AN
EFFORT TO CHECK THE DIEM IT
SEIZE POWER TO UNILATERALLY --
TO DO THIS AND YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE IT'S AN IMPROPER
EXERCISE OF HIS FORTY TWO I
DECLARE A BENEFIT MANDATED.
WHEN -- THE REGULATORY AGENCY
LACKS ANY LEGAL GROUNDING TO DO
SO SO -- YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I'M
GOING TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
HERE -- SO MR LOUISE US YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT RETROACTIVITY ACT
[inaudible]
RETROACTIVITY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU?
IS IT ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT A
LIABILITY WHAT WHAT IS IT WHAT
IS IT THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT -- RETRACTED BECAUSE WHEN
I AND ON A PREP AND I'M GONNA
FRAME THIS IN A CERTAIN WAY
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD WE HEARD FROM
OVER HERE.
THAT SOMEONE WHO IS DIAGNOSED
THEY HAVE A ONE TO TWO WEEK
WINDOW.
AND SO CENTER I FIVE GOT CANCER
I'M NOT GOING TO WAIT TILL
JANUARY. FOR YOUR BILL -- SO --
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA HAVE TO PULL
THAT MAKE THAT DECISION PULL
THAT TRIGGER WHATEVER -- BUT I'M
NOT GONNA WAIT SIX MONTHS OR
FIVE MONTHS OR WHATEVER IT IS
BECAUSE I WANT TO LIVE IN IT MAY
JEOPARDIZE MY MY ABILITY TO LIVE
SO.
SO I SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE THING
BUT I WHAT WHAT ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT IS THE
RETROACTIVITY THAT THAT.
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT WHAT IS THE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY THAT YOU.
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WELL I MEAN
IT.
IT'S AN UNKNOWN LIABILITY --
ANYONE WHO -- FOUGHT THAT THEY
SHOULD RECEIVE THIS BENEFIT --
COULD COME BACK AND BASICALLY --
YOU KNOW HOLD MY MEMBERS LIABLE
FOR NOT COVERING IT WHEN WE WERE
TOLD WE DON'T HAVE TO COVER IT.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION PICKED AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
PACKAGE THAT EXCLUDED THIS
BENEFIT?
SO -- WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE SCOPE OF THAT COULD BE
BUT WERE WORRIED ABOUT THAT --
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
IT WAS NOT BAKED INTO OUR RATES
INTO OUR PREMIUMS MOVING FORWARD --
IT'S NOT A COVERED BENEFIT SO
IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY RATES THAT HAVE JUST BEEN
SUBMITTED TO STATE REGULATORS --
AND COVER CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN --
YOU KNOW WE JUST GOT GOOD NEWS
TODAY THAT.
YOU KNOW PREMIUMS ARE NOT GOING
UP VERY MUCH THIS YEAR OR NEXT
YEAR.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY AND WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT OF WHAT
IS AND WHAT ISN'T A COVERED
BENEFIT WHEN YOU CONSIDERED WHEN
YOU CONSIDER A NEW BENEFIT FROM
BEING ENACTED.
YOU GET AN INDEPENDENT REPORT
FROM AN INDEPENDENT BODY THAT
TELLS YOU WHAT THE COST IS GOING
TO BE.
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS ARE GOING
TO BE -- AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
HEALTH BENEFITS ARE GOING TO BE
OF THAT COVERAGE BASICALLY BY
SAYING THAT ANYTHING IS COVERED.
BASED BY REGULATORY FIAT.
YOU'VE ESSENTIALLY SURRENDERED
YOUR ABILITY TO MAKE A A
CONSCIOUS AN INFORMED DECISION
ABOUT.
OF THE AFFORDABILITY OF HEALTH
CARE AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S A BAD PROCESS.
TO BASICALLY -- CODIFY INDIAN
SANCTION.
SO.
I'M SORRY WHEN I GO BACK TO THE
TO THAT SO FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
WERE DOES THAT RETROACTIVITY
AND IS THAT?
IS THAT.
IN YOU KNOW.
THE DOCTOR IS SAYING THAT THERE
ARE GUIDELINES FOR INSURANCE AND
AND THAT YOU CAN'T YOU'RE GOING
BACK THAT FAR.
BUT YOU ARE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS SO FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHERE DOES THAT
RETROACTIVE NEGATIVITY -- END
YEAH WELL SO.
YOU MISTER I'M NOT GONNA BE
OPTION ON THE ISSUE I I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE TIME ONE WOULD
WOULD BE AND IT.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
STATUTES OF LIMITATION THE
CONTRACTS YOU KNOW WITH PLANS
ENROLLEES LIKE I CAN CERTAINLY
LOOK INTO THAT.
BUT I I DON'T KNOW IT'S NOT A
NOTABLE IT'S NOT DEFINED IN THE
BILL AND WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
FIND IN THE BILL ANYWAY AS WE
THINK.
THAT PEACE SHOULD BE COMPLETELY
REMOVED AND IF IT'S REMOVED.
WE CAN HAVE AN OPEN DISCUSSION
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL ONLINE -- YOU KNOW A
PROPERLY CRAFTING THIS BENEFIT
ON A PROSPECTIVE BASIS WE DON'T
EVER.
GO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON A
BENEFIT MANDATE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME IN MY RECOLLECTION
THAT WE'VE EVER DONE THAT.
BUT WE'RE WILLING TO SETTLE THIS
ISSUE AND WE'VE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS TO DO THAT BUT THE
YOU KNOW THE DECLARATORY
EXISTING WALL LANGUAGE WOULD
HAVE TO BE ROOM FOR THE BILL IN
ORDER FOR US TO TO DO THAT.
SO THEN I GUESS MY NEXT WHICH SO
CDI.
SAYS ONE THING DIEM EIGHT C.
SAYS ANOTHER -- WE HAVE A
CONFLICT HERE HOW DO WE FORESEE
THAT CONFLICT BEING RESOLVED.
IS IT BECAUSE IT THROUGH THIS
BILL.
THAT'S OUR GOAL AND OUR HOPE AND
AGAIN FROM WHAT THE MHC IS
TELLING US THIS IS NOT CHANGING
THOSE TIME LINES.
AT ALL IT'S JUST PROVIDING.
THE THE PATIENT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET CARE WE'RE NOT DELVING
INTO LIABILITY WERE NOT EXPOSING
THE PLANS. TO THAT EXTRA
LIABILITY ACCORDING TO THE MHC I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THE GENESIS
OF THIS.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM THE HEALTH PLANS SO IT'S
HIS JOB TO OPPOSE IT IT'S MY JOB.
TO WHAT YOU KNOW I YEAH I'M JUST
SAYING YEAH WE HAVE A DISAGREED
WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND
I'M.
ME I I'VE WANTED NOTHING BUT TO
HAVE THE HEALTH PLANS ON BOARD
FROM THE VERY FIRST CONVERSATION
I HAD IN MY OFFICE WHERE I SAID
I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS BILL --
SO I'M NOT LOOKING TO TO NOT
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BUT I AM
LOOKING. TO TO YOU KNOW AFTER
DECADE.
YOU KNOW GET THIS SOLVED AND
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE INMATES SEE
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT.
SO ARE YOU OPEN TO DISCUSSING
REMOVING THE RETROACTIVITY OF
THIS.
WE CAN CAN CAN I HAVE HER
RESPOND RIGHT WELL I'D ACTUALLY
LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU BECAUSE
IT'S YOUR BILL I'M I DON'T MEAN
I'M TRYING TO I'M NOT TRYING TO
BE OBSTINATE BUT I JUST.
ARE YOU OPEN ARE YOU OPEN ON
OPEN BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MHC.
AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE DOING
IT.
IS AN UNDERMINE BY THAT.
CONVERSATION IS THAT MAKES SENSE
I MEAN I MAY COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
BUT I'M OPEN TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE WE HAD THAT CONFERENCE
CALL LAST WEEK SPECIFICALLY ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND THE INMATES HE WAS SAYING
IT'S A RED HERRING IN.
YOU KNOW FROM WHAT I WAS TOLD I
WAS.
THEY WERE ALL ON THE CALL --
THAT THIS IS NOT WHAT'S BEING
ADVERTISED AS A REASON TO OPPOSE
IT AND IT'S NOT WE NEXT WE NEED
THIS LANGUAGE SO.
I WOULD.
BE HAPPY TO HAVE EVERYBODY IN
THE ROOM WITH THE MHC YOU'RE
WELCOME TO SIT IN THAT AS WELL.
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BUT
I'MNOT PROMISING THAT I'M GONNA
TAKE THAT AMENDMENT DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE.
YEAH I JUST I'M ASKING IF YOU'RE
OPEN TO YEAH DISCUSSION THIS
PERHAPS A LITTLE OKAY.
AND CAN I HAVE MY TECHNICAL
PERSONRESPOND AS CHAIR SURE YES
SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS WAS VERY CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD
THESE LIMITATIONS THAT ARE BAKED
INTO THE STATUTES.
ARE ENFORCED -- BY THE INMATES
SEE REGULARLY THEY PUT A SEVERE
RESTRICTION ON ALLEGED
RETROACTIVITY ALREADY -- SO IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY IT'S
EXISTING LAW -- PEOPLE THAT ARE
PASSED THESE STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS ESSENTIALLY THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS TO FILE A
GRIEVANCE WITH THEIR HEALTH PLAN
AND OR TO FILE FOR AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW WITH
IT APARTMENTS -- THAT SIX MONTHS
IF THAT HAS PASSED IT'S ALREADY
PASSED AND THIS IS NOT CHANGING
AT THE EXISTING LAWS YOU SIDE SO
THOSE REMAIN INTACT.
BUT I THINK THE POINT AND THAT'S
THE POINT I'M GETTING AT AND I
THINK THE CONCERN OF THE HEALTH
PLANS AND I'M JUST.
TRYING TO CLARIFY THIS FOR MY
MIGHT.
THERE IS A NO LIABILITY IN THAT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAY PERIOD.
WE DON'T KNOW -- WHO MIGHT CLAIM
THAT ON THERE MIGHT BE PEOPLE
PAID OUT OF POCKET I?
DIDN'T THINK THIS WAS A WAS A
COVERED BENEFIT -- BELIEVING
WHAT CITY I SAYS THAT IT'S NOT A
COVERED BENEFIT SO SO THERE IS
CONCERN ABOUT THAT SO IT IS.
A BIT UNPRECEDENTED FOR US TO GO
BACK RETROACTIVELY.
AND APPLY THIS RETROACTIVELY SO
THAT'S THAT'S MY CONCERN STATE
AGENCIES WHO DISAGREE -- WHERE
IS THIS ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE
RESOLVED TO GET OUT?
IS IT RESULT BY THIS BILL OR IS
IT RESOLVED IN.
GOD FORBID A COURT.
I DON'T KNOW WE THINK THE BILL
RESOLVES IT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
I'M ON THE MUCH I COULD ADD TO
IT OTHER THAN I WAS A LITTLE --
I THINK A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED AS
WELL.
IN TERMS OF BUT THAT THE SAULS
RETROACTIVITY OR NOT.
I'M STRUGGLING.
TO HOW TO GET DOWN AND I'M STILL
SUPPORTED BY THE LIKE HOW YOU.
REALLY GET THERE BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T HAVE. THREE DIFFERENT
POSITIONS.
WITH THREE DIFFERENT SUGGESTIONS
RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING I'M OPEN
TO THAT CONVERSATION.
BUT IN EVERYTHING THAT'S BROUGHT
US TO THIS POINT WITH THE
INMATES SEE.
THIS IS WHAT WE FEEL CLARIFIES
AND CODIFIES WITHOUT CHANGING
THOSE TIME LINES IN EXISTING LAW.
SO THAT'S WHY WE DON'T THINK
THIS IS OPENING UP ANYBODY TO
ANY ADDITIONAL LIABILITY
[inaudible]
THAT'S MY OPINION.
CAN WE ADD ONE MORE THING.
CAN I JUST ADD -- AS A PATIENT
ADVOCATE OF SORRY.
YEP
.
I'M SORRY I'M TRYING TO GET
CLARIFICATION ON SOMETHING
.
I'M SORRY I WAS ASKING FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION ON SOME NUMBERS SO
SO PLEASE YOU CAN GO AHEAD.
SORRY I'M SO.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT AS SORT OF THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PATIENT
ADVOCACY COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR MANY YEARS
WITH SENATOR PORTANTINO. TO
UNDERSTAND -- WHETHER THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE COVERED
IT WAS ALWAYS BEING EXCLUDED
BECAUSE IT WAS BEING CATEGORIZED
AS AN INFERTILITY TREATMENT.
AND THAT IS WHAT I THINK HAS
ALWAYS OR HISTORICALLY BEEN
EXCLUDED.
FERTILITY PRESERVATION WAS NOT
AND EXPRESS EXCLUSION IN THESE
PLANS I MEAN THIS IS A A
TREATMENT THAT IS MEANT TO
PREVENT STERILITY IN THESE
PATIENTS AND THEY HAVE NO.
CHOICE BUT TO UNDERGO CANCER
TREATMENT RIGHT THEIR LIVES AT
RISK AND SO THE THE HIGH COST OF
THE SERVICES PUTS IT OUT OF
REACH UNLESS THEY DO IT
IMMEDIATELY.
AND SO WE WERE TRYING TO
DISTINGUISH AND UNDERSTAND HOW
THE REGULATOR -- EVEN VIEWED
THIS SERVICE WHETHER PREVENTION
OF STERILIZATION IF YOU WILL IS
SOMETHING BASIC AS A BASIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICE THAT SOMEONE
IS ENTITLED.
TO AND YOU KNOW AFTER ALL OF OUR
MEETINGS AND DISCUSSIONS ARE
UNDERSTANDING FROM DIEM EACH SEE
WAS.
YES THIS IS HOW WE VIEW THIS
THIS IS A BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICE AND SO IF IT'S MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR THAT PATIENT
MEANING.
THEY'RE FACING POTENTIALLY
STERILIZING TREATMENT THEN IT'S
A COVERED SERVICE AND IT SHOULD
BE -- COVERED BY THE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND THAT IS WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING THROUGH FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS AND SO THE
PURPOSE OF THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IN MY UNDERSTANDING WAS.
NOT TO GO BACK AND CREATE ANY
KIND OF YOU KNOW LIABILITY ON
YOU KNOW FOR ANYONE IT WAS
REALLY JUST TO BE PERFECTLY
CLEAR.
THAT THIS IS ALREADY SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE CUT BEING COVERED
FOR THESE PATIENTS AND THAT THAT
WAS THE POSITION OF THE
REGULATOR.
AND SO WE WERE TRYING TO CAPTURE
THAT IT WAS NOT. TO CREATE SOME
LONG TRAIN OF LIABILITY.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THOSE DATES ARE
ALREADY CODIFIED WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THOSE STATES.
SO IS IT AND AND AND I AND I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE THIS AND AND I
HANG ON TO IT.
I APOLOGIZE BECAUSE THIS HAS
GOTTEN A LITTLE CONVOLUTED HERE
SO IS IT YOUR IMPRESSION THEN
FROM YOUR FROM.
THE H. D. DAMMIT.
THE WHATEVER THE MHC THANK YOU --
THAT THIS IS.
IN THEIR VIEW AN ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFIT [inaudible]
YES.
BASIC HEALTH BETTER YES BUT THAT.
BUT WILL DEBATE THE ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS ARE DEFINEDBY
THE A FOUR BY OUR BY COVER
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THE DISCONNECT IS HERE BECAUSE I
I DON'T BELIEVE.
IT IS AN ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFIT AND AND THAT IS WHERE
THAT IS SO THAT'S WHERE THE
DISCONNECT DOCTORS IS SCHOOLING
ME HERE.
THEY'RE SAYING IT'S A BASIC
HEALTH NEED WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN AN ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFIT.
I THINK THAT'S WHY I HAVE TO DIE
AS A REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION YEAH THAT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
OUR UNDERSTANDING FROM THE MHC
IS THAT -- THAT THIS IS A BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICE AS PER KNOCKS
KEEN AND THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
COVERAGE FOR THE CLARIFICATION
COMES INTO PLAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
INTEREST MISTER BIGELOW
[inaudible]
ONCE.
I THINK YOU JUST CHARACTERIZED
IT IT'S AN NEEDS WANT.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE SOUNDING HERE
IN SOME WAY -- I THINK YOU HAVE
THE PLANTS WHO ARE SAYING IT'S
NOT COVERED.
IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU RECOGNIZE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL REPRESENT SO
WHEN SOMEONE COMES TO YOU YOU'RE
GOING TO CHALLENGE THAT.
AND ANDERSON TO BE AN ISSUE OF
THAT IN A COURT.
WE'RE HERE TO SOLVE THE ISSUE.
IT SEEMS THE DISCONNECT IS THE
DATE OF TIME TO WIN THIS STARTS
SO THEY EITHER YOU CAN COME BACK
AND BIT IT AS A PROGRAM.
THAT HAS A SERVICE SENATE
[inaudible]
OR NOT.
BUT IT'LL BE A REQUIREMENT FROM
THIS LEGISLATURE SO YOU NEED I
THINK SENATOR TO CHOOSE A DATE
THAT IT STARTS.
FORGET THE RHETORIC TO RETRO
ACTIVITY WE PICK A DATE.
THAT THIS BILL TAKES EFFECT.
AND THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE A
DATE AFTER SOME DATE IN JANUARY
SO THAT YOU HAVE TIME AS PLANS
TO BID AND AND GET THAT ALL IN
PLACE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT WOULD BE THE
EASIEST SOLUTION HERE.
WHY WOULD YOU?
WITH THAT NOT WORK FOR YOU.
I KNOW YOU'RE THINKING IT
THROUGH.
TAKE YOUR TIME BECAUSE THIS IS
RE CLARIFYING RECERTIFY.
THE EXISTING LAW UNDER KNOCKS
KEEN.
SO IT'S ALREADY IN A FACT BY
EVIDENCE OF THE FACT THAT
EVERYONE OF THE APPEALS THAT ARE
DENIED [inaudible]
GETS OVERTURNED.
SO THERE THE THE THE NECESSITY
FOR A START DATE IS IN.
THERE BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY IN
EXISTING LAW.
THAT IS WHAT THE CHAIR WHICH IS
TALK ABOUT THERE'S A DISCONNECT
WHAT IS BELIEVED AS A SERVICE
AND WHAT IS IN REALITY
[inaudible]
A SERVICE.
THAT IS THE DISCONNECT AND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO RESOLVE IS THAT
DATE.
SO WELL I MEAN I I BILL WOULD
NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY
ONE IS NOT AN URGENCY.
NO I I I SO THAT'S WHEN THE
THAT'S THE DATE I GET IT SO.
BUT THE RETRO ACTIVITY THAT
FOLDS BACK IN.
SO YOU WHAT THOSE ARE ALL
COVERED BY EXISTING LAW THERE'S
ALREADY TIME LINES IN PLACE THAT
WE'RE NOT CHANGED.
MAYBE I COULD.
IF I COULD -- MISTER LOUISE IF
YOU COULD MAYBE RESPOND THAT AS
WELL YEAH I MEAN ONE THING I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW -- THE
APPEALS THAT I BELIEVE THE
AUTHOR AND THE I'M ADVOCATES ARE
REFERRING.
TO OUR APPEALS WERE FILED --
UNDER THE INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW PROCESS UNDER THE IT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND IF I COULD JUST BE LABOR
JUST A LITTLE BIT WHAT WHAT
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW IS
OUR I AM ARE.
IT IS TO RESOLVE DIFFERENCES IN
OPINION ON THE MEDICAL NECESSITY
OF A COVERED SERVICE SO IF YOU
SERVICES COVERED BUT THERE'S A
DISPUTE OVER THE MEDICAL
NECESSITY OF THAT COVERED
SERVICE.
VAN Vì AND ROLLY AND OR THE
PROVIDER HAS THE ABILITY TO
RESOLVE WITH THE HEALTH PLAN
FIRST AND THEN GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE --
TO RESOLVE THIS QUESTION OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY NOW.
SOME FERTILITY PRESERVATION
SERVICE APPEALS HAVE BEEN GOING
TO INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW
NOW SETTING ASIDE WHERE THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE OR NOT -- WHEN THERE
IS A DECISION? TO OVERTURN A
PLAN TO NILE BASED ON MEDICAL
NECESSITY THAT IS AN APPEALABLE
BY THE PLAN AND THAT IS BINDING.
RIGHT SO THE PEOPLE THAT OF ONE
UNDER I AM ARE -- THAT AT LEAST
BY LAW SHOULD BE GETTING THEIR
SERVICES PAID FOR YOU KNOW
WHETHER WAS RIGHT TO REFER HIM
THERE AND ON THE FIRST PLACE.
HIS SEPARATE QUESTION BUT IF WE
IF THE HEALTH PLANS LOSE THAT I
AM ARE.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE COVERED -- OR
THEY SHOULD BE UNDER LAW SO.
GOING BACK TO THE POOL LET'S
LET'S TAKE THAT ON FOR MOM.
BUT ANYWAYS I WANTED TO ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS
THIS NOTION OUT THERE THAT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
APPEALED ARE NOT HAVING THEIR
SERVICES.
SO CLARIFY FORCE IS THIS A
BENEFIT OR IS IT NOT A BENEFIT
COVERED IT IS NOT A REQUIRED
BENEFIT SOME PLANS DO COVER IT
AS A WRITER.
WHICH MEET WHICH UNDERLIES
UNDERLINES THE NON REQUIRED
NATURE OF THE BENEFITS SOME
PLANS IN THE GROUP MARKET
WOFFORD AS A WRITER MEANING THAT
IT'S OPTIONAL.
AND THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE REGULATOR BUT FUNDAMENTALLY
NO THIS IS NOT A SERVICE THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE COVERED.
UNDER THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS OR UNDER ANY STATUTE
MANDATING ITS COVERAGE SINCE
THEN.
AND SO YEAH SO THE ANSWER IS NO.
SO NO WONDER SENATOR YOU'VE
STRUGGLED WITH THIS FOR A COUPLE
OF GO ROUNDS TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER THE PIECES IT'S IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT. ONE SIDE SAYS
YES IT SHOULD BE COVERED.
THE OTHER SIDE SAYS NO IT'S NOT
COVERED.
AND WE ARE.
FOR CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
TRYING TO DECIDE SIMPLY ON HOW
HOW WIN WIN SO WHEN COULD A
REASONABLE DATE.
BE PUT IN PLACE TO SOLVE THIS
ISSUE.
LET ME ASK THE PLANTS.
WHAT WOULD BE A REASONABLE DATE
SO WHAT WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS TO STATE THAT -- A
HEALTH COACH.
SKEWS ME SORRY HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN CONTRACT ISSUED
AMENDED A RENEWED AFTER JANUARY
FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY SHALL
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR THE
SERVICES JUST PARAPHRASE -- SO
THAT IS OUR THAT IS OUR OFFER IN
ITS ONE PART OF A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE OFFERED TO
HELP.
PARAMETERS AROUND THIS INCLUDING
THE REMOVAL OF THE DECLARATORY
EXISTING LOSS I THINK THE BODIES
HEARD PRETTY MUCH.
WHAT THIS IS THE CENTRAL POINT
SO IS THAT A REASONABLE TIME FOR
YOU [inaudible] TO PUT.
IN YOUR BILL.
THE JANUARY ONE HOW DO YOU
RESPOND TO THAT.
I THINK IT NEGATES THE BASIC
THESIS THAT WERE REDIFF
REAFFIRMING.
CURRENT LAW.
BY SAYING THE NEW.
THIS THE CURRENT LAW DOESN'T
APPLY UNTIL THAT DATE I THINK
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND I'M WILLING TO GO BACK TO
THE MHC AND ASK THEM WHY THAT'S
A PROBLEM BUT THAT WOULD BE MY
FIRST TAKE ON IT.
THAT -- IT CHORE UNDERMINES THE
BASIC THESIS OF WHY WE'RE HERE
SO WHEN ARTICULATED THAT'S YOUR
INTENT OF THE BILL AND I MAINLY
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION I'M
NOT WILLING TO COMMIT TO THE
OUTCOME.
I I GET THAT.
I WAS GOING TO SUGGEST IF YOU
ARTICULATED THAT IF WE WERE ABLE
TO ARTICULATE THAT IN SOME WAY.
TO DATE AN ABSENT THAT THERE'S
ANY OTHER ABILITY TO CALM TO
CONFLICT RESOLUTION THE DATE
WILL BE RECOGNIZED -- JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY SAY THAT A LOT
I ACTUALLY -- INTERJECTED RIGHT
I SURE THINK.
I THINK THE I MY MY
INTERPRETATION OF THIS WHOLE IS
HE'S NOT.
READY TO DO THAT YET BUT I WHAT
I DO SENSE IS THAT THERE IS A
WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN.
AT HIS PROPONENTS AND THE HEALTH
PLANS -- WHICH I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO DO THAT -- BUT I THINK
YOU SEE THE CONUNDRUM THAT THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES AND I THINK
BUT BUT I I HOPE THAT.
THE COMPANY THAT THE BILL MOTION
COMMITTEE YOUR YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY OKAY -- WITH.
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION.
FREE **** IT'S RESPECTFULLY
HOUSE FOR NINE VOTE.
OR NOT.
SO WE WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
BURKE.
A SECOND BY.
MISTER WAS AT MISTER SANTIAGO
OKAY.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHEN I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA LOW
VOTING LEMOND Là MON I MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN AYE
ROMMEL'S.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
YOU HAVE NINE VOTES THE BILLS
OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLLOVER FOR OTHER SAT ON THANK
YOU OKAY SO.
CALLING ALL MEMBERS. TO COME
BACK WHEREVER YOU ARE FROM WHERE
YOU ARE -- WILL START AGAIN WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
NUMBER -- ONE FOUR SIX SEVEN
NINE TEN SIXTEEN PUT MADAM SIX
TREES PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AREA HI.
IS THERE AN AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. FOURTEEN
AS FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER --
TWO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE AND
BECAUSE OF LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GIVES ME.
MAYES.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'M SORRY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BIGELOW NO.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
LIMON.
LEVANTA AYE.
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. TEN WE
HAVE TEN VOTES THAT THE BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FORTY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
I'M SORRY ON THREE BIGELOW AYE
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE [inaudible]
LOAN.
LIMON AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I HEY. FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB ONE FIFTY NINE SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
LIMON.
LEVINE AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THIRTEEN THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB THREE OH FIVE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA I'M SORRY MAYES.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
LIMON.
LEVINE AYE.
SANTIAGO. ONE ZERO I THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SP FOUR OH SEVEN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
LOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
THIS IS.
ITEM.
SB FOUR OH SEVEN ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN OKAY IS THERE AND I
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO HI. ZERO THAT'S TWELVE
ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
BIGELOW -- FOUR THIRTY EIGHT YES
IT'S NOT [inaudible]
BIGELOW NO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO
CARILLO AYE.
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE. THIRTEEN ONE
THAT'S THIRTEEN TO ONE THAT'S
FOUR MORE VOTES THAN THE SENATE
ACCORDING TO BUY TALLY WITH
SENATOR HERTZBERG -- ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SP FOUR FIFTY TWO
SENATOR JONES.
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CARILLO.
CARILLO I THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. TWELVE THAT'S
TWELVE ZERO AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB SIX HUNDRED SENATOR
PORTANTINO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING. TEN ZERO HAS
TEN ZERO AND THEN SEVEN S..
I REMEMBER FIFTEEN SB SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR ALLEN
PLEASE.
OPEN THE ROLLING CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE.
THIS AREA.
HI NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO SO THAT --
THAT COVERS IT -- I THINK THAT.
SENATOR -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON AND MCCARTY MAY HAVE
COME IN WHEN WE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS SO.
EVERYONE ELSE.
WE WERE WITH AND THEN I SAID NO
MISS BURKE AND UP -- MISTER
MAYES ARE.
COMING BACK SO WE'LL WAIT FOR A
FEW MINUTES FOR THEM AND SO.
CAN. TWELVE EVERYBODY CUT.
EVERYBODY VOTER DIE.
SO VOTE CHANGE ITEM NUMBER --
TWELVE SP -- FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
MISTER BIGELOW THOSE FROM NOW --
TO NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW NOTES NOT VOTING
[inaudible] THIRTEEN ZERO IT
WILL COME BACK IF YOU.
MISS WALDRON AND MISTER MCCARTY
WILL GO THROUGH AND FIND WHERE
YOU HAVEN'T VOTE.
SO.
AB ONE HOUR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE -- FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
ZERO I DON'T WANT I DON'T WANT.
TO ITEM -- TWO S. -- SB TWENTY
NINE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON NOW.
TENTATIVE TENDED [inaudible]
TO THANK [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
IT WAS ALMOST WITH THOSE WHO IN
THEIR RIGHT NOW WHICH WAS.
OKAY.
CAPTION OKAY THAT'S IT WILL WAIT
FOR MISTER MASON WAS BURKE.
FOR A FEW MINUTES.
OTHERWISE AND I JUST WANNA SAY
OF THIS IS OUR LAST MEETING THE
LAST HEARING THIS YEAR I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU.
TO OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED WITH US THIS YEAR
THERE MAY BE ANOTHER ME HEARING --
SOMETHING ELSE COMES UP BUT THIS
OUR LAST SCHEDULED HEARING I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION I WANT THINK A ARE
SERGEANTS -- FOR HELPING -- TO
KEEP KEEP THINGS ROLLING FOR US
AND KEEP THINGS MOVING ALONG
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND I'M AND
THEN OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK SO --
THANK YOU TO ONE AND ALL IT'S
MUCH APPRECIATED.
BUT WE WILL AND WE'LL JUST HANG
OUT.
WAIT FOR MR MAYS MISSED.
THE GUY GOT YOU FOR ALL OF US
DID.
GOT YOU FOR EVERY DAY WE GOT WE
GOT YOU
.
OKAY IT APPEARS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY MISTER MASON MISS
BURKE WILL NOT MAKE IT BACK SO
THAT WILL -- AND THE HEARING
TODAY -- THE HEARING IS CLOSE
THANK YOU